hey welcome to draft academy my name is
mike in this course i'm going to teach
you guys everything you need to know to
get started using c sharp now c sharp is
an extremely powerful programming
language and it's used in millions of
applications around the world there are
literally thousands of things you can do
with c-sharp and there's tons of
different applications for this language
it's extremely powerful and i'm excited
to be bringing you guys a course that
will teach you everything you need to
know to get started so we're going to
start the course with the basics we're
going to install c-sharp we're going to
install a text editor called visual
studio we're going to get everything set
up and we'll start writing our first
program i'm going to teach you guys the
basics of programming so we're going to
look at some of the core programming
concepts things like working with data
variables data types getting input from
users then we're going to move on to
some more advanced stuff we'll talk
about things like loops and if
statements and different data structures
and finally we'll talk about some
object-oriented programming concepts
things like classes and objects
inheritance
all that fun stuff if you're new to
programming or you just want to try and
pick up c sharp then this course has
something for you i'm really excited to
be bringing you guys c sharp tutorials
it's an awesome language and there are
literally thousands of things you can do
with it so without further ado let's get
started let's go into the course and
start learning some c-sharp
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how to install and get everything
set up to start programming in c-sharp
now in order to start programming in
c-sharp we're actually just going to
need one thing which is going to be a
program called visual studio community
and this is basically a program that
will allow us to write our c-sharp
programs and this is what's called an
integrated development environment and a
lot of times you'll hear people call
those ides it's essentially just a
special program where we can write and
work with our code so in this case this
is an ide that will allow us to work
with the c-sharp programming language so
i'm over here on this website it's just
visual studio.com
forward slash vs forward slash community
and this is the website where we can go
to download this you'll see over here
there's an option to download on windows
and then there's also an option to
download on mac over here so you can
just click whichever one you need in my
case i'm on a windows so i'm just going
to go ahead and click the one for
windows so click this and that should
start downloading in we should get an
installer that we can use to install uh
visual studio so once that's downloaded
i'm just going to click it and we'll go
ahead and run this installer so when the
installer loads up you'll see that we
have this uh little window over here and
basically this is a little program that
we can use to install what we need now
here's the thing this visual studio
program is huge and there's tons of
stuff
that you can actually do with it so you
can see there's all these different
things we can install i mean there's
probably like over 100 gigabytes worth
of stuff that we can install here we
basically just need this guy over here
that says dotnet desktop development
this is all we're going to need we're
going to be building something called a
console application which is essentially
like the simplest type of application
that we can build and you'll see over
here it says the install size is around
three gigabytes so that's actually not
too bad some of these things are like a
couple you know maybe like a dozen
gigabytes or something like that so yeah
click this dotnet desktop environment
and i'm just going to click install and
we're going to go ahead and install that
hopefully it doesn't take too long all
right so once that is finished
installing and downloading we can just
go ahead and click launch and we can
launch right into visual studio you'll
see over here it's asking me to sign in
you don't actually have to sign in so
i'm just gonna click not now maybe later
and then over here we have a bunch of
options um you'll see down here there's
this drop down i'm just gonna click
general so just make sure it's on
general and then we can pick whatever
style we wanna have we can just go with
the basics so i'll just stick with blue
and then i'm gonna click start visual
studio
all right so this should go ahead and
open up this little starting page i'm
just going to click out of this we don't
need to have this up here and i'm going
to go over here and we're just going to
click file and i'm going to click new
project so we want to start a new
project and this is basically going to
allow us to write our applications so
over here inside of visual c-sharp you
can just click here and you'll see over
here there's an option for console app
this is what we want so don't get too
intimidated by all this different stuff
like i said before visual studio is a
very powerful program and it can do a
lot of stuff
but make sure you just click console app
and we should be good so i'm just going
to click ok and actually down here we
can give this a name so
i'm just going to call this draft and
then we could store it wherever we
wanted to store it so when this loads up
you'll see that we now have this file
open and this is just called program.cs
and that dot cs extension stands for c
sharp and then down here we have a basic
program
so this is essentially a very simple
program and it's sort of like the
template for a program and don't worry
too much about what all this stuff is in
the next video i'm going to talk you
guys through what all this stuff is what
it means and we'll actually write our
first program but for now we have
everything set up so we're ready to go
and ready to get started with c sharp
development
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how to write your first c sharp
program we're also just going to talk in
general about what a program is so we're
going to look at the different
instructions that we can give to the
computer and how those instructions are
going to play out and allow us to write
applications
so over here we basically just have our
basic project set up and i kind of went
over how to do this in the last tutorial
and we're basically given this little
text file and this is a c sharp file so
it's called program.cs
and that cs extension stands for c-sharp
you'll also notice over here in our
solution explorer we have a bunch of
different stuff here so i called my
project draft and then over here i have
like this little properties thing this
references thing
really all we need to worry about over
here and i know there's a lot of stuff
over here is this guy right here
program.cs that is the uh c sharp file
that we're going to be programming in
that's the file we're going to be using
for this course
and this is really all you need to worry
about over here
and you'll see that this is actually
populated with some code with some text
by default you'll see up here we have
all of these little commands it just
says using system using
system.collections all this stuff
essentially what this is doing is it's
just configuring the file so you don't
really have to worry too much about what
this stuff is up here just make sure
that you leave it alone you know don't
touch it but basically there's some
things that we're going to have to use
with c sharp and up here we can specify
that we want to use them so there's
these things
called system and there's all these
different things that we can use inside
of there but for the most part you can
just kind of leave this alone for now
we'll talk more about what this is
later in the course but for now you
don't have to worry about it too much
down here you'll see this says namespace
draft you'll notice that this is
actually the same name as the project
that we're using and essentially that's
what this is saying it's saying that
we're in the draft project and actually
this is doing some more stuff again
we're going to talk more about
namespaces later in the course so you
don't really have to worry about that
too much and really you know all the
stuff up here you can come just leave
alone you don't have to worry about that
in the beginning and down here we have
these two curly brackets and these two
curly brackets essentially just signify
that our like program is starting
so inside of these curly brackets we can
actually write some code and the
computer will be able to execute that
code here we have this keyword class and
it's called program
now a class is essentially just a
container where we can store a bunch of
code so inside of a class we can write
all of the code for our program and
it'll be able to be executed so again
we're going to talk more about classes
as we go on through this course but for
now just know that a class is
essentially just a container where we
can put code
down here we have this line of code here
it says static void main and this is
actually what's called a
method or a function again we're going
to talk more about methods and functions
uh later in the course but this is sort
of just like another container where we
can put code and this is a very
important container because this
container is where we can put all the
code that we want our program to execute
so this main method or this main
function any code that we put inside of
here in other words any code that we put
inside of these open and closed curly
brackets is actually going to get
executed by our computer so whatever
code i want my program to have i need to
put it inside of this main
method so inside of these open and
closed curly brackets now i understand
that like a lot of this stuff doesn't
make sense right now and to be perfectly
honest with you we kind of have to just
set our program up this way in order for
it to work it doesn't matter if this
stuff doesn't make sense like obviously
you're not going to understand what all
this stuff is but just know that that's
totally fine like as a beginner you're
not expected to know any of that you're
not going to know any of that through
this course though i'm going to be
teaching you guys all of this stuff so
by the end of the course we'll
understand what all this stuff is doing
why it's important why it's there but
for now i just need you to trust me that
we need to have everything set up like
this in order for our programs to run
and any code that we're going to write
inside of our c-sharp file that we want
to execute i want to put in between
these two curly brackets inside of this
main block okay
so now that we've kind of talked about
the structure a little bit we've talked
about you know some of the stuff that we
needed to know what i want to do is
actually
write our first line of code so we're
going to go ahead and write a line of
code which is going to print something
out onto the screen so one of the things
that is really useful to do when writing
a program is to print out information
and the most basic instruction that we
can give the computer is basically
telling it to print something out so i'm
going to go ahead and do that down here
we're going to write our first line of
code so i'm just going to say
console with a capital c
dot
right
line and then i'm going to make an open
and closed parentheses
and i'm going to make a semicolon now
inside of these open and close
parentheses i'm going to make an open
enclosed quotation mark and i'm just
going to type out hello world
so essentially what we're doing here is
we're telling c sharp that we want to
write this text out onto the screen so
let's kind of look through this line of
code i'm saying console.writeline
and this is an instruction so
essentially i'm telling c sharp that i
want to write a line out onto the
console and as you'll see in a second
the console is basically just a little
window where we can see the output of
our program i'm saying console.writeline
and inside of these parentheses i'm
specifying what i want to write out onto
the console or out onto the screen
and i'm basically just saying hello
world and then over here i'm putting
this semicolon now whenever we're
writing a line of code in c-sharp
whenever you're done writing that line
of code you always need to end it with a
semicolon so for the most part whenever
you write an instruction whenever you
write a line of code you're going to end
it with a semicolon and that's very
important and as a beginner you're going
to forget to put the semicolon trust me
everybody does but eventually you'll
just kind of get used to putting it in
there all right so i'm going to go ahead
and save this file and now we're going
to actually execute this program so when
i say execute the program essentially
what i'm doing is i'm telling the
computer to go through and carry out all
of the instructions that we specify
in our program right now we only really
have one instruction which is telling
the computer to write a line out onto
the console i'm going to come up here
and you'll see there's this start button
so this is going to be our best friend
throughout the course anytime i want to
run my program i'm going to go ahead and
click this start button so i'm just
going to click it and when i click this
start button my program is actually
going to run and if you look there
you'll see that a black window popped up
for just a second i'm continuing to run
it essentially what's happening is
c sharp is printing out the line hello
world onto a little console window
that's popping up but the problem is
that our program is printing that out
and then the program is terminating so
that window is going away
in order to keep that window up so we
can see what's going on i'm going to
type out another line of code i'm just
going to type
console.readline
[Music]
and basically what this line of code is
going to do is it's going to keep that
little console window up until i enter
in a line of text so now when i run my
program
you guys will see that this little black
window up here
appears and then it stays open so before
it was kind of flashing up and then
disappearing but now it's going to stay
open and you'll see we're printing out
hello world onto the screen now if i
click the enter key so i'm just going to
click enter
this window is going to go away so
anytime i click enter that basically
tells our program that we're done
executing it so we want it to go away
and that's basically all we have to do
so i can write out instructions in here
i can write out lines of code i can
press the start button and then i'm
basically executing all of those lines
of code and then obviously to get out of
this like i said you can just like type
a space and type enter or you can really
type anything and just hit enter and
then the program will terminate this is
sort of our first c sharp instruction
and like i said console.writeline
basically just writes a line of text out
onto the screen and then we can include
this console.readline
instruction in order to keep that window
up so we can see what we're printing out
now that we know how to print out
something onto the screen i want to show
you guys how we can draw a little shape
so i'm actually going to
get rid of this and i'm going to go
ahead and copy this right line piece of
code and i'm going to paste it a few
times down here so we're actually going
to use this line of code to draw out a
shape onto the screen so down here i'm
going to create like a forward slash and
then up here we'll create one
and i'm going to keep creating them in
this little pyramid structure
so now you can see i have like a little
pyramid and then i'm gonna make vertical
bars going all the way down so
essentially we're drawing out like a
little right triangle
and actually you know i'm gonna put
underscores here
so it's a little more obvious so you can
see i'm saying console.writeline and in
each one of these instructions i'm
telling the computer to write out a
different line so over here we're
writing out like the tip of the triangle
over here we're writing out the middle
part of the triangle and then the base
of the triangle
so now let's go ahead and run this
program
and you'll see over here we're actually
able to print out this entire triangle
so just by using that one instruction
that console.writeline instruction i was
actually able to draw out an entire
shape onto the screen
so now i'm going to go ahead and exit
off of this and you'll see down here how
easy it was for us to write this program
now essentially what happens is when i
click that start button c-sharp is going
to go into my program it's going to find
this block of code right here main
it's going to go inside of these curly
brackets and it's going to execute each
instruction in other words each line of
code one after the other so it's going
to start with this first line of code
and it's basically going to say okay
what does the user want me to do they
want me to
write a line out onto the console and
they want me to write this text so it's
going to go ahead and write that out
onto the console then when it's done
with this instruction it's going to come
down here and go to this second
instruction it's gonna do the same thing
it'll execute that instruction and then
it'll go down here execute this one and
execute this one so essentially what c
sharp does is it executes all of the
lines of code all the instructions that
we give it
in order and one of the things you're
going to learn is that when we're
programming the order matters so the
order in which you write these lines of
code actually matters a lot so if i was
to take this instruction over here
and i was to
paste it up here in the top now this is
going to change the way that the shape
looks so instead of having that normal
triangle you can see we have this kind
of like funky looking shape where the
base is up at the top and that's because
we changed the order of the program now
essentially all a program is is just a
set of instructions specified in a
particular order that's it and as we go
through this course and as you learn
more about c sharp you're going to find
more and more complex instructions that
you can use so the more complex
instructions you're able to give the
computer and the better you're able to
organize them and order them the more
powerful your programs are going to
become so obviously we only really know
two instructions we know this
console.writeline which prints something
out in console.readline which basically
pauses the screen until we enter
something but just with these two lines
of code we were actually able to draw
out an entire shape onto the screen and
that was pretty cool the takeaways from
this tutorial is that a program is
essentially just a set of instructions
that the computer is going to follow
the order of those instructions matter
and in c-sharp the instructions that are
going to get executed by the computer
are going to be inside of these open and
closed curly brackets in this main block
of code and that's sort of the bare
basics of writing a c sharp program you
know we were able to print something out
onto the screen we were able to pause
that little console until we told it we
were done and now we can kind of go
forward and start learning more and more
complex instructions and more and more
complex ways to build our programs
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about variables in c-sharp now
a lot of times when we're writing
programs in c-sharp we're going to be
dealing with a bunch of different data
so there's going to be all sorts of
information all sorts of data values in
our programs and a lot of times that
information those data values can be
kind of hard to keep track of and manage
so in c-sharp we have a special
container called a variable and a
variable is basically just a container
where we can store
some of that information so i could
store a piece of data or a piece of
information that i want to keep track of
and manage in my programs
inside of a variable so in this tutorial
i'm going to show you guys what
variables are why they're useful and
we'll look at kind of how we can work
with them in our c-sharp programs so
down here i have written out this very
basic program
it's basically just writing out a bunch
of lines of text it says there once was
a man named george
he was 70 years old he really liked the
name george but didn't like being 70. so
this is basically just a program that i
wrote which
prints out a little story onto the
screen so if i was to run this program
you'll see that we get this story it
says there once is a man named george he
was 70 et cetera so i'm able to print
out this story onto the screen so this
is a perfectly functional program we've
actually written a program which prints
out a story right but let's say that i'm
looking at my story and i'm thinking to
myself hmm i think i want to change the
character's name
well let's say instead of having the
character be named george i want to
change his name to john well i can just
come up here i can search through my
story and find every place where i'm
mentioning the character's name and i
can change it to
john
cool so now my story is updated i went
through i manually changed the name to
john and everything works
but let's say i'm looking at it again
and i'm thinking maybe i want to try to
appeal to a younger audience so instead
of having the character be 70 why don't
we have the character be like 35
so once again i can just go through i
can look through and every time they
mention the character's age i can just
change it to
35. here's the next one
cool so i basically went through and i
found out every place where the
character's name was mentioned and i
changed it to 35. here's the problem
though in order to make those changes in
order to modify the character's name and
the character's age i had to go through
and manually change it at every place
inside of my program so every place
where the character's name was mentioned
and the character's age was mentioned i
had to go in and manually change it now
this is fine with a story that only has
four lines but imagine if this story had
hundreds of lines and the character's
name was mentioned like a hundred times
or their age was mentioned a hundred
times imagine then if you wanted to
change the character's name or imagine
even if you just wanted to keep track of
and manage the character's name and it
would be extremely difficult so the more
lines in this story that i write the
harder it becomes for me to manage the
character's name and the character's age
and these are two good examples of
pieces of information in our program in
order to make a situation like this a
lot easier we actually have something in
c sharp called a variable and a variable
is basically just a container where i
can store a specific data value and then
when i want to use that data value
instead of having to actually like type
it out and type out what it is i can
just refer to the variable's name so i'm
going to show you guys how we can create
variables and how we can keep track of
and manage the different data in our
programs like the character's name and
the character's age so up here above my
story i'm actually going to start
creating a variable and the way that we
can create a variable is by giving c
sharp some information so this is going
to be a line of code and the first piece
of information that i want to give to c
sharp is going to be the type of data
that i want the variable to be able to
store so remember variables are just
containers that we can store values
inside of and different containers can
store different types of information
some containers can store text others
can store numbers others can store like
other values like true or false values
we're going to go ahead and create a
variable that's going to store the
character's name so i want to create a
variable that can store text because the
character's name is text and we can do
that by creating a string so a string is
essentially just like a string of
characters and it's basically just plain
text so i'm going to go ahead and tell c
sharp that i want to create a string
variable so i'm just going to type out
string
and then what i need to do is give this
variable a name so remember these are
containers and generally when we're
naming a variable we want to name it
according to what's going to be stored
inside of it that way we can identify
what's in the variable i'm just going to
call this character name and you'll
notice here that i'm separating these
words so the second word has a capital
letter all right so i created my
variable and it's going to store a
string which is just plain text and then
i'm going to set it equal to something
so i'm going to say character name is
equal to and now i'm going to give this
a value so i'm going to give this a
value that's plain text i'm going to
make an open and closed quotation mark
and then whenever i write a line of code
i always want to end it off with a
semicolon just like that all right now
inside of these quotation marks i can
write out the string of characters of
the string of text that i want to store
inside of the character name variable so
we're just going to store the
character's name which is john so i can
just type out john
up there in addition to creating a
variable to store the character's name i
also want to create another variable to
sort the character's age so let's go
ahead and do that now the character's
age is actually going to be a number
right so the character's age is a number
it's not really plain text like this
and if we want to create a variable to
store a number we can create a variable
called an integer variable so int stands
for integer and an integer is basically
just a whole number so a number that
doesn't have decimal points and i'm just
going to go ahead and name this
character age so again giving it a name
and i want to show you guys another way
that we can create these variables so in
addition to saying like string character
name is equal to john i could also just
say int character age i could put a
semicolon here and then i could come
down here and give this a value so i
could say like character age is equal to
and now we can give this a value so we
said 35 and you'll notice that when i
give this a number value i don't need
these quotation marks you only need the
quotation marks with a string
so
these are two different ways that i can
create a variable and they're doing
exactly the same thing up here i'm just
saying string character name and i'm
giving it a value right away over here
i'm doing what's called declaring the
val the variable i'm basically saying
that we're going to have a variable
called character age i'm not giving it a
value right away and then down here i'm
assigning it a value of 35. so these two
this guy and this guy up here are doing
exactly the same thing
so now that we have these variables in
other words now that we have containers
where we can store the different values
of the different pieces of data that
we're going to work with in our programs
i want to actually use those variables
inside of our story so i'm going to show
you guys how in addition to printing out
this plain text i can actually print out
the value that's stored inside of the
variable so over here you'll notice that
i'm typing out there once was a man
named john but i don't want to have to
type out john anymore i just want to be
able to refer to that variable so what i
can do is i can actually get rid of this
and i'm going to come outside of these
quotation marks
and over here i'm going to put a plus
sign
and this plus sign basically means i
want to like append some text or i want
to append a value
onto the end of this text over here and
what i want to do is just put the name
of the variable so i'm just going to
type out character name
and what this is going to do is it's
going to print out there once was a man
named and then a space and then it's
going to print out the value that's
stored inside of the character name
variable so it's going to print out john
so let me demonstrate that let's go
ahead and run this program
and you'll see over here we're still
printing out there once was a man named
john
except i didn't have to physically type
out john down here all i did was use
this plus sign and essentially just
append on or people call this
concatenate on
the value that was stored inside the
character name variable and this is
extremely useful so i could do the same
thing down here with this other
occurrence of the character's name i can
just say
character name and now over here it's
going to do the same thing it's going to
say he really liked the name and then
whatever the value that's stored inside
of this character name variable we can
do the same thing for the age so over
here you'll notice that i have the age
is 35 but remember we created this
variable up here to store that so what i
can do is i can actually get rid of this
and i'm actually going to make two open
and close quotation marks here and i'm
going to make two plus signs and then in
between here i'm going to type out
character age essentially what i'm doing
is i'm telling this right line
instruction that i want to print out he
was with a space and then i want to add
in the value that's stored inside of the
character age variable which is going to
be 35 and then i want to add into that
years old so basically what we're doing
here is called concatenating a string
i'm saying i want to type this out plus
i want to type the value that's in here
plus i want to print out this stuff over
there and then finally we can do the
same thing down here so i'm going to get
rid of this
and i'm just going to type in
character age so i've replaced every
occurrence of the character's name and
the character's age with these variables
so now let's go ahead and run our
program i'm just going to click this
start button and you'll see over here
we're printing out the same exact story
as before it says there once was a man
named john he was 35 he liked the name
john and 35. so i essentially just
replaced john and 35 with the variables
that are storing them now what's cool
about these variables is if i wanted to
for example modify the character's name
or the character's age i can just modify
it up here so let's say we wanted to
change the character's name to tom and
we wanted to make him like 25. well now
i only have to modify those two values i
only have to update them in one spot
and it's gonna update throughout my
entire story so now the character's name
is tom and he's 25 throughout the entire
story
and the variables just make it a lot
easier for us to keep track of and for
us to manage
those pieces of information now you'll
notice that i only created variables for
the character's name and for the
character's age and that's because those
two pieces of information are occurring
multiple times in the story i didn't
create a variable for the word once or
for the word man because i just didn't
need to you know what i mean that's not
like a distinct piece of information
that we want to keep track of but the
character's name and the character's age
are definitely pieces of information
that we're going to want to keep track
of in store
so that's sort of how we can use
variables to make it easier to manage
the data in our programs now i want to
show you guys another cool thing we can
do with this
let's say that halfway through the story
i wanted the character's name to change
i could actually come down here and
halfway through printing out the story i
can modify the value of one of these
variables so i could say
character name and i could just give
this another value so i could say
character name is equal to mic and again
i need this semicolon at the end here
don't forget that
now halfway through the story the
character's name is actually going to
change so if we run the program
you'll see over here it says tom and
then down here the name is mike so i was
able to update the value that was stored
inside of our variable halfway through
and that's another cool thing is these
variables you can give them one value
and then later on in the program you can
change that value so that's really the
basics of working with variables we
really learned two things we learned how
to create variables and we learned how
to use them inside of like a print
statement over here now there's a lot
more to learn with this and actually in
the next tutorial i'm going to be
teaching you guys about the different
types of information that we can store
inside a variable so over here we stored
a string of text and we also stored a
whole number which is called an integer
but there's a few other types of data
that we can use and work with so in the
next tutorial we're going to learn about
all of that stuff
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about data types in c-sharp now
in c-sharp we're going to be dealing
with all different types of data and
information and generally when you're
writing programs there's going to be all
different types of information that
you're going to be working with so i
want to talk to you guys today about the
different types of information and the
different types of data that we can
represent and work with in c sharp
so down here i'm basically going to be
showing you guys all the different you
know data types that we can use and i'll
be doing that by creating variables so a
variable is just a container where we
can store a data value or a piece of
information
and i'm going to be creating different
variables that can store the different
types of data that we can work with in c
sharp so the first type of data that we
can work with is plain text so anytime
you want to represent or you know use
just regular old text inside of your
programs you want to use something
called a string so i'm just going to say
string and i'll just call it phrase and
i'm just going to set it equal to a
string so a string is basically just
denoted using an open and closed
quotation mark and then inside of the
quotation marks you can just put
whatever string you want to represent so
in here i could put like
draft academy and now this is going to
be a string with the text draft academy
inside of it so that's a string and
that's going to come in handy a lot
another type of data that we can store
is instead of a string of text just
going to be one single character so if i
want to create a character i can just
say char and maybe this could be like
the grade you get on a test or something
and then when i create a character i
want to use these single quotation marks
just like that and then inside here i
can put one single character so i could
put like an a
or a b or a c or something like that but
the important difference is that with a
character i can only put one single
character i can't put a bunch of stuff i
can only put one so any single character
is going to work
but you need to make sure that there's
only one in there when you need more
than one character then you want to move
up to the string all right so that's the
two ways we can store plain text so
things like characters and you know
strings of characters we can also work
with numbers and the most basic type of
number we can create is called an
integer and an integer is basically just
a whole number so it's one of the
counting numbers like one two three four
five basically an integer doesn't have
any decimals in it so i can just say int
like that int
and this could be like someone's age for
example so maybe someone's like 30.
and you'll notice that when i create a
number like any numbers or you know
whether it's an integer or another type
of number you don't need quotation marks
around it like you do up here so you can
just type out the number as is
and you can do whole numbers like this
like an integer we could also do uh
negative numbers and you can just put
the minus sign right in front of it and
uh c sharp is going to be able to handle
negative numbers just fine so in
addition to integers we can also
represent decimal numbers so a decimal
number would be you know like 60.3 or
something like that
and instead of storing inside of an
integer we can actually store it in one
of three data types so there's actually
three different data types that we can
use to represent decimal numbers and
they're called there's a float a double
and a decimal and these basically allow
you to store decimal points more and
more specifically so these range from
least accurate with the float to most
accurate with the decimal data type so
if you really want to be super super
super precise with the decimal point
that you're using you want to use a
decimal point and this would be used for
things like money or you know really
anything that you need to be extremely
exact with you want to use a decimal
a float is going to be less precise so
it's going to be able to be taken to you
know a less precise amount of decimal
places and then double is kind of just
like right there in the middle for the
purposes of this course i think for the
most part we're just going to be using a
double i think for most use cases a
double is going to be just fine but like
i said if you're doing something you
know where you need to be extremely
accurate like with money or something
then you want to use that decimal so i
can just say double and i can give this
a a name so we could make this like a
gpa right someone's gpa might be like a
3.2 and so this is a good example of a
decimal number you could also make these
just normal numbers so i could make it
like 3.0
but anytime i'm using a decimal number i
need to include this point zero in there
so that's um integers and doubles and
those are the two main types of like i
said numbers we're going to be able to
represent whole numbers and then decimal
numbers and then we kind of touched on
like the different types of decimal
numbers
so after um characters and numbers we
just have one more like
core data type that we're going to be
representing which is going to be called
a boolean and a boolean is essentially
just a true or a false value
now a lot of times in programming we're
actually going to want to be able to
store true false information and this
might not be something that is super
intuitive to you if you've never
programmed before but a lot of times
storing information in the form of a
true or false value is going to come in
handy so
if i want to create a boolean i can just
say b o o
and boolean is just a you know it
essentially just means a true or false
value so i can say b-o-o-l and i can
give this a name so we could call this
like
is male
and this boolean will basically tell us
whether or not someone is a male so i
could say true if we're a male
or you could also say false but those
are the only two values that this should
have it should either be true or it
should be false that's it and that's
basically why booleans are useful
because they can only have two values so
for the most part i would say these are
the core data types that you're going to
be using in c sharp now there are a few
other data types that we could get into
um they're a little bit more obscure and
they're not used as commonly as these
data types for the most part you're
going to be fine with just strings
characters
numbers and then boolean values
99 of the stuff that you want to do
you're going to be able to do with just
this data and as a beginner you only
really want to concern yourself with
these data types now i do want to point
one more thing out is you can represent
these data types outside of variables so
if i came down here and said like
console.writeline
i don't have to like store this type of
data inside of a variable if i don't
want to like i could just print out like
a string like hello down here like this
isn't actually stored inside of a
variable or i could print out like a
number like if i want to print out 30 i
could do that and then when i run my
program you can see we printed out just
fine
these are what we would call constants
and a constant is basically just like a
value just like this 30. it's not stored
in a variable we're not keeping track of
it anywhere it's just kind of written
out you can do the same thing for
booleans so obviously you don't have to
store this information inside of
variables a lot of times it's useful to
do that but if you don't want to you can
just kind of use it like that so that's
the basics of data types in c sharp and
these are going to come in handy a lot
really with just these types of data up
here you can write a bunch of awesome
programs
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about
strings in c sharp now strings are one
of the most useful types of data that
you're going to be working with in c
sharp so in this tutorial i want to just
show you all the ins and outs of working
with strings we're going to look at some
of the cool things that you can do with
them and how you can really leverage the
power of strings inside of your programs
so down here you'll notice that i just
have this little console.writeline
instruction and basically this is just
going to write out some text onto the
screen so if i wanted to create a string
i can just make these open and close
quotation marks and then in here i could
type out some text so i could type out
like
draft academy and now when i run my
program it's going to go ahead and print
that on onto the screen so anytime that
i want to represent some sort of like
plain text or really any type of text in
my program i can do it with a string and
there's actually some cool things you
can do with these strings so let's say
for example that i wanted to print out
draft academy but i wanted to print out
draft on one line and then academy on
the next line i can use something called
a new line character so i could actually
say backslash n
and this is a special character
that we can use in c sharp strings which
is basically going to specify that we
want to type out draft then a new line
then academy so now when i run my
program
you'll see that draft and academy are
printed out on different lines so that
can come in handy when you're writing
out your strings there's also another
way so if let's say that i wanted to
write out a
quotation mark if i put a quotation mark
here you'll notice that this quotation
mark effectively ends this string and
then this over here is just causing an
error
if i want to actually print out a
literal quotation mark that's not you
know delineating the string i can just
use that backslash again and now we'll
be able to print out that quotation mark
no problem just like that so those are
some cool little things that we can do
inside of our strings
you can also take a string and store it
inside of a variable so a variable is
just a container that you can store
different pieces of information so if i
wanted i could create a variable over
here just say string and we can just
call it like phrase and i'm just going
to set it equal to this text over here
which is just going to be draft academy
and then down here i could just print
out the values stored inside of this
variable so i could print out the values
stored in the phrase variable and we're
still printing out draft academy so
that's kind of cool
another thing you can do with strings is
called concatenation and
concatenation is the process of taking
one string and then appending another
string onto the end of it so you're
essentially just adding two strings
together so for example over here i can
say string phrase is equal to draft
academy
and then i could use this plus sign and
then this is basically going to add
another string onto that so i could say
like
is cool and now when i print out phrase
it's going to be printing out draft
academy is cool so it basically just
added those two strings together we
would call that concatenation and that
can be really useful another thing we
can do in our programs is find out
information about our strings so
sometimes you might want to figure out
different pieces of information about
the string
figure out some attributes about it so
let's say we wanted to figure out how
many characters were inside of this
string i could just say phrase dot
length and that's with a capital l and
now what this is going to do is it's
actually going to tell me how many
characters are inside of this string so
now we should get like 15 yeah because
there's 15 characters
inside of draft academy so that's a
really cool way we can find out some
information about the string
in addition to finding out information
we can also use things called methods
and we're going to talk more about
methods in a future tutorial but
essentially all you need to know right
now is that a method is basically a
little block of code that we can call
which is going to perform a specific
task so these are basically like little
pre-defined snippets of code that we can
sort of tell to execute and then they'll
do something so we can use methods on
our strings and they'll either give us
information about our strings or they'll
modify our strings in some way so over
here if i want to use one of these
string methods i can just say the name
of the string or i could also type out
like a literal string like that and then
i can just say
dot so i'm going to say phrase dot and
now i have access to all of these
different methods so if i want to use
one i can just type out the name of the
method and i'll show you these can kind
of
do little things with our string so
let's say that i wanted to take this
string over here and convert it into all
uppercase well there's actually a method
that's going to be able to do that for
us so i could say phrase dot 2
upper and then i'm going to make an open
and closed parentheses and now this is
actually going to take this string over
here convert it into uppercase and then
print out the uppercase string onto the
console so now when i run the program
you'll see we get draft academy all in
caps you can also do the same thing for
lowercase so i could say like two
lower and now it'll do the same thing so
it should all be entirely lowercase now
which it is so that's one way that we
could like modify the value of a string
we could also find out some more
information about this string so imagine
we wanted to figure out if this string
of text contained a certain like
sub-string of text right so maybe we
wanted to see if this string had the
word academy in it i could say phrase
dot
contains
and now what i'm actually going to do is
i'm going to give this contains method a
piece of information and this is called
a parameter so this over here this
contains method will tell us whether or
not this phrase string contains like a
certain set of characters or something
and in order to use it i have to tell it
what i'm looking for so i can say
phrase.contains
and in here i could say like
academy and this is basically going to
return a true or false value telling me
whether or not the phrase draft academy
contains the word academy
and we should get a true value back
because it does so you can see over here
we get true
but if i said over here like
academies now all of a sudden we should
get false back because that string is
not included in the phrase string it's
not included in draft academy and that
can be kind of useful you can like tell
whether or not a certain string contains
another string or another character
another thing we can do is figure out
the different characters inside of a
string so i'm going to get rid of that
let's say that i wanted to figure out
what the first character in my string
was right so let's say there's a
situation where i have a string like
phrase and i wanted to figure out what's
the first character in that string well
i can actually access individual
characters and print them out so i could
say like phrase and i can make an open
enclosed square bracket
and inside of here i can just put the
index of the character that i want to
print out inside of the string so if i
put a zero here this is going to tell me
what this first character is so phrase
square bracket 0 should be printing out
a capital g
and you see over here it does if i
wanted to figure out what the third
character in the string was i can say 0
so i can say 2
and now this should print out that r for
us
and you can see we get r so if you
haven't caught on by now when we're
indexing a string we actually start at
zero
so if i was going to assign index
positions to each of the characters
inside of this string i would say that
the g character is at index position
zero the i character is at index
position one the r character is at index
position two the a character is at index
position three etc so the first
character this g is actually at index
position zero
inside of the string and that's
basically just a way that c sharp and
actually a way that most programming
languages index strings
so
when i say phrase 0 this is actually
referring to this first character so
let's see if we could print out this a
over here well it's basically going to
be zero one two three four five six
seven eight so this is gonna be at nx
position eight so if would if i put an
eight in here
now we should be able to print out that
capital a
which we do over here
so that's sort of how
string indexes work and using this
information we can use another string
method so again i'm just going to say
phrase dot and i want to show you guys
another method that we can use it's
called
index of and index of is basically going
to tell us not only if a string contains
a certain value but it'll tell us at
what index position that value is
located inside of the string so for
example if i came over here and said
academy
this is going to tell me at what index
position academy
starts inside of this string
so when i run my program
you'll see that we're getting an 8 over
here and we just sort of saw that that
capital a character started at index
position eight
so basically what this is saying is that
academy
starts at
zero one two three four five six seven
eight so it starts here
in addition to passing in a string like
that i could also pass in a character
and remember a character is just an open
and closed single quotation mark and
then inside here i could put like an f
and now this will tell me the location
of the first f inside of this string so
it'll give me that index and you can see
we get four and that's because
zero one two three four this starts at a
four and that can be pretty useful
there's also gonna be the situation
where uh the character isn't in there so
if i put a z in here you'll notice that
there's no z up here so in this case
we're actually just gonna get a negative
one back and a negative one is always
gonna signify that the character is not
inside of the string so that can be
pretty useful so that's how we can use
phrase.index of and that'll come in
handy a lot there's also one more of
these string methods that i want to show
you and it's called sub string so i can
say phrase dot
substring string i can make an open and
close parentheses and i'm actually going
to need to give this a value so
basically what this will allow me to do
is it'll allow me to
grab a part of this string so i could
grab like one part of the string and
then print that out onto the screen and
we can give this one parameter we can
give this one argument in other words
one piece of information and that's
basically the index where we want to
start grabbing the string at so let's
say that i only wanted to grab this
academy word and print this out well
remember academy starts at index
position eight we already saw that so
this capital a is actually in exposition
eight in the string if i put an eight in
here this is now going to grab the
characters starting at eight and going
to the end of the string so now we
should just print out academy which we
do down here
you can also in addition to just passing
in the starting index you can pass in a
length and you'll notice that i'm just
using a comma here and that's going to
delineate that i want to pass in another
value so i'm passing in the starting
index and i can also pass in how many
characters i want to grab
so i can say i want to start grabbing
the characters at 8 and let's say that i
only want to grab 3 characters so over
here i can put a three
and now we're gonna start at eight and
we're gonna grab one two three
characters so we should get aca printed
out onto the screen
and you can see that we do so that
substring method can come in handy so
that's kind of the basics of working
with strings and you know so i showed
you guys kind of how we can work with
them different things we could do like
concatenation and we can also print out
things like new lines we also looked at
getting information about a string like
the length and you know individual
characters in the string we talked about
the string indexes we also talked about
different methods that we can use to do
different things with our strings so
hopefully that kind of gets you up to
speed with why strings are awesome and
how they're useful and to be honest with
you there's a lot more of these little
methods that you can use and if you want
you can just go online and google
c-sharp string methods and you'll find
like a huge listing of probably at least
you know a few dozen of these different
methods that you can use to either find
out information about or modify your
strings
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about numbers in c sharp now
numbers are one of the most common types
of data that you're going to be working
with in your c-sharp programs so in this
tutorial i just want to kind of give you
guys a full walk-through of you know how
to use numbers
the different types of numbers that we
can use and we're also going to look at
some cool things that we can do with
numbers uh things like you know complex
math operations and you know just
dealing with numbers in general so this
is gonna be pretty cool down here i just
have a basic program it just is
basically writing out a line of text so
if i wanted to for example like write
out a number i can just represent a
number by just typing it out so i could
say like 40 or 20 or i could say like
negative
5.763
really any type of number
i can work with and there's really two
main types of numbers there's a whole
number which we would refer to as like
an integer and then there's a decimal
number so those two different types of
numbers are going to be really useful in
our c-sharp programs but it's important
that you note that c-sharp does
distinguish between those two types of
numbers so there is a big difference
between working with whole numbers and
working with decimal numbers and that's
something that you just want to be aware
of as you sort of go through and write
your programs and so you know basically
i could just type in a number here like
50 and then i'd be able to print it out
onto the screen just over there like
that so numbers are pretty easy to work
with we can also do math with numbers so
i could say like five plus eight and now
instead of printing out five plus eight
like the literal text five plus eight c
sharp is actually going to go ahead and
perform this math operation for us so
it's going to print out the result of
adding five and eight together so we're
going to get 13 over here
and we can use addition like that we
could also use subtraction which is just
that uh hyphen we could use a forward
slash which would mean division and we
could also use a asterisk which is going
to represent multiplication so any of
those different operations the four
basic math operations you can use
we can also use another operator which
is called the modulus operator so for
example if i could say like
five and then i can put a percent sign
here and i could say two and we would
read this as five
mod 2 and this modulus operator right
there essentially what this is going to
do is it's going to take 5 it's going to
divide it by 2 and it's going to give us
the remainder so 5 divided by 2 is going
to be 2 with a remainder of 1 and that's
exactly what's going to get printed out
so we should just print out
one over here which we do so sometimes
you might be interested in getting the
remainder of a particular division
operation and this is going to go ahead
and do that for us we can also represent
like mathematical equations so
one thing we can do is specify order of
operations so if i was to say like four
plus two
times three
actually what's going to happen is the
multiplication is going to happen first
and then this addition is going to
happen so it's going to be 3 times 2 6
plus 4 so we should get 10.
and that's just sort of following normal
order of operations rules but if i
wanted to change up the order of
operations i can use parentheses so i
could say like 4 plus 2 which is going
to be 6 and now it'll be 6 times 3 so
we're going to get 18 instead of getting
that 10. so you can use those
parentheses to
sort of change around the order that
different calculations are getting
performed and those can be pretty useful
i also want to talk to you guys about
the difference between using integers
and using decimal numbers so like i said
an integer is just a whole number a
decimal number would be you know a
number that has a decimal on it
something like that
and actually like i said c sharp does
distinguish between these two types of
numbers so if you're adding or
subtracting or multiplying or doing some
sort of mathematical operation with an
integer and a whole number sometimes the
results you get are going to be a little
bit different so if i was just to say
like 5.0 plus 8.1 if i was to perform a
math operation with two decimal numbers
then i'm going to get a decimal answer
back so i'm going to get like 13.1
but if i was to perform a mathematical
operation with an integer and a decimal
so 5 plus 8.1 and you'll notice that
this is now an integer because it
doesn't have a decimal point again we're
going to get a decimal back so i'm going
to get a decimal number back just like
that but when we do math operations with
two integers then we're always going to
get an integer back so if i said 5
divided by 2 and you'll notice that
these are both integers i'm actually
going to get an integer answer back so
really this should be like two point
something right should have some long
decimal point but when i actually run my
program you'll see that i'm getting an
integer value back i'm getting a two
back but if i was to convert this to a
double so if i said 2.0
so now this is going to be a decimal
number we're going to get a decimal
answer back so that's basically how that
works so any math operation that you do
with two integers no matter what you're
going to get an integer back but if you
do a math operation with a decimal and
an integer then you'll always get a
double back and that'll kind of come in
handy as you're working with these
different types of numbers another thing
we can do is we can store numbers inside
of variables so i could create a
variable up here let's create one for
int so i'm just going to say int num and
i can give this a value of like six
right so now this container num is
storing the value of six and then i
could print that out just like i
normally would so i could just say num
down there and it'll print out that six
there's another cool operation which we
can do which will basically allow us to
increment this number so down here i
could say num
plus plus and basically what this is
going to do is it's going to add 1 to
the number so now instead of being six
since we're adding one to the number
this is going to be seven so when i run
my program you see we'll get seven and
you can do a similar thing with minus
minus so i could say like num minus
minus and now instead of getting a six
we would get a five and those are going
to come in handy just as like a
shorthand as we go through
our c-sharp journey all right so those
are sort of the basics of you know
working with numbers and you can see we
can store them in variables and we
talked about you know interacting
between uh integers and decimal numbers
and i also want to show you guys um some
other stuff we can do so a lot of times
in our programs we're going to want to
be able to perform different math
operations so there's all sorts of math
operations you know like using exponents
and using the square root or you know
even doing like logarithmic stuff or
sine cosine tangent stuff like there's
all sorts of math things
that we might want to be able to do
inside of our programs and i'm going to
show you guys uh there's these things
called methods and a method is basically
just a block of code that's going to
perform a specific task so i can do
what's called call a method and when i
call a method it's basically going to
like perform a specific task or a
specific function for me and there's a
bunch of these different math methods
that we can use in our c-sharp programs
and the way that we can get access to
them is just by typing out math with a
capital m and then i can say dot and now
i have access to all these different
math operations so you'll see down here
i can like scroll down through this list
and there's all these different things
that i can do i'm going to show you guys
a couple of these cool
math methods is what they're called and
you can kind of see what they do so
one is just math.abs and this stands for
absolute value so i can make an open and
close parenthesis and inside of here i'm
going to put a number so if i said like
negative 40 this is going to give me
back the absolute value of negative 40
which is just going to be 40 as you can
see there's another one which is called
pow and this stands for power so i'm
actually going to be able to give this
two numbers and it's going to spit out
the first number taken to the second
number so if i said like three and then
two over here this is going to give me
back three raised to the second power so
we should get nine and you can see we do
and that's this will also work with like
decimal numbers so i could say like 3.8
raised to the second power and now we
should be able to run this as well so
14.44 and you can also do the opposite
so we could say like sqrt this is going
to stand for
square root so if i put like a 36 in
here
now i'm actually going to
get back the square root of 36 so we
should get 6 back
and we do there's also another useful
method which is called max and with max
you can actually pass two numbers into
these parentheses so i could say like
four and ninety and max is actually
going to spit out whichever one is
bigger so it'll tell us which number is
the biggest and so this should give us
90 as you can see down there and that
can come in handy there's going to be a
lot of situations in
c sharp where you might have two numbers
maybe they're stored inside of variables
and you don't necessarily know which one
is bigger so you can use that math
function to figure that out there's also
another one called min and that just
does the opposite so now this will give
us the smaller of the two numbers so
we're going to get four back there's one
more that i want to show you guys um
it's called math.round
and this is a really great way to round
numbers so when i say math that round i
could pass this like a
decimal number like 4.3 and this will
round it just according to standard
rounding rules so you can see we get
four but if i was to up this to like 4.6
now we're going to go ahead and get a 7
or a 5 back so we get the 5 back there
so those are just some basic you know
math operations that you can do and you
can see i'm using this visual studio
text editor when i just say math and
then i click this dot
you can see all of these different
options are showing up down here so
there's all these different um methods
that we can call i mean there's all
sorts of stuff we can do
and you can kind of just like play
around with each of these like see what
they do but for the most part like any
major math operation that you're going
to want to be able to do there's usually
going to be a method for it or at least
a method in here to help you with it so
you definitely want to check that out
and you can also just google like c
sharp math methods on line and you'll
find a huge listing of them so that's
sort of the basics of you know using
math and then also working with numbers
again numbers are extremely important so
you want to make sure that you're you
know up to date and sort of up to speed
with how to use them and how they
interact with each other and all that
stuff in c sharp
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how to get input from a user in c
sharp now one of the cool things about c
sharp is we can actually have our
programs interact with the user so i
could run my program and i can actually
like give it some information and it can
use that information to do different
things and when you think about it most
programs that you probably use on a
daily basis are going to allow you to
input information into them and then
depending on the information that you
input they're going to do different
things so today we're going to look at
the most basic form of that which is
just you know allowing the user to
basically like type in a value and then
we can use that value to do something so
down here i have a simple program set up
you'll see i'm just saying
console.writeline and i'm writing out
hello and then down here throughout this
course so far i've always included this
line of code
in our little programs and basically
with this line of code has been doing is
it's been allowing us to see the output
of our programs right so if i include
this read line when i run my program
then i can see what gets output so i can
see hello right it sort of stays on the
screen but if i was to get rid of this
line like if i remove this when i click
the start button you'll see that that
window like pops up really quick and
then disappears and that's because we're
essentially executing this line of code
and then once that line of code's been
executed there's nothing else to execute
right there's no other instructions for
the computer to like carry out so
essentially the program just terminates
and then that window disappears we've
been using this console.readline
instruction in order to keep that black
window up on the screen in order to keep
the console on the screen
because what this line does
is it actually waits for the user to
enter in a line of text so this line
essentially pauses the execution of our
program and waits for the user to enter
something so if the user hasn't entered
something then our program is
essentially just paused so actually if
you guys watch over here my program is
essentially paused but if i was to enter
something and then click enter the
program terminates right because now
this line of code down here has finished
executing but what's cool about this
line is like i said it pauses the
program so we can sort of see
what's happening another thing that this
line of code does though is it allows us
to enter in a line of text and we can
actually use this instruction over here
to get input from the user so i'm going
to show you guys how we can do that in
this tutorial i want to basically design
a little application that's going to ask
the user for their name it's going to
get their name and then it's going to
say hi to them so i'll basically be able
to type in my name and the computer will
be like hey mike what's up so the way we
can do that is with a couple steps the
first thing we want to do is prompt the
user for information so i'm basically
just going to
write out a line and i'm just going to
say console.write
[Music]
and you'll notice before we were using
console.writeline
now essentially the difference between
right and right line is that when we say
rightline this is going to print out a
line of text and then it's going to go
on to a new line so it's basically going
to print out and then we'll go on to a
new line when i just say console.write
it's not going to go off to a new line
it's just going to kind of print out on
the same line and you guys will see what
i mean in a second
so i'm going to use console.write
because i'm basically going to be
prompting the user so i can just say
enter your name and then i'm going to
make a colon
so this is going to be our prompt for
the user now the next thing that we want
to do is we want to be able to allow the
user to enter in a line of text so i can
do that like i said with
console.readline just like that
and this is going to pause the program
and wait for the user to enter in a line
of text
but here's the thing i don't just want
to let them enter in the line of text i
want to be able to take the text that
they enter and store it inside of a
variable right like if they just enter
text
it's no use to me if i don't know what
they entered so i want to be able to
store the value that they entered
somewhere and we can do that with a
variable so whenever we use this
console.readline
it's basically going to get the line of
text that they enter as a string so it's
going to store the line of text that the
user enters as a string of characters so
i'm going to create a variable
and we're just going to call this name
and i'm going to set this equal to
console.readline so i'm saying string
name
is equal to
console.readline just like that now the
last thing i want to do is i'm actually
going to write something out to the
screen so i'm just going to say
writeline
and over here we're going to print out
hello and then we're going to print out
the name that the user entered so i'm
basically just going to print out hello
plus
name
so basically the user is going to enter
in their name and then we're going to
say hi to the user and you'll notice i'm
keeping this read line down there just
so we can see
what the output is so let's go ahead and
run this program and we'll see what
happens so over here it says enter your
name and you'll notice over here it's
letting me enter this on the same line
as this prompt and that's why we use
that console.write instead of
console.writeline so over here i'm just
going to type in my name my name is mike
and now when i click enter the value mic
is going to get stored inside of that
name variable and then we're going to be
able to print it out on the screen so
you can see down here we're printing out
hello
mic
and that's essentially all we needed to
do to get this program to work so
we used
console.readline which paused the
program and let the user enter in a line
of text when they hit enter the value
that they entered gets stored inside of
this name variable and then we printed
it out onto the screen so that's pretty
cool and we can actually do this as many
times as we wanted so if i wanted i
could get another piece of information
from the user so i'm going to do that
i'm going to copy this and we'll come
down here
and this time i'm going to ask them to
enter in their age
so over here we're going to create
another string and we're just going to
call it age and again i'm just going to
say console.readline
so now in addition to having their name
we also have their age so i can say
hello
name
and then i can basically tell them how
old they are so i can say you are
and then we'll print out their age
so now we're saying hello whatever the
name is you are whatever their age is so
let's go ahead and run this program now
we're getting two pieces of information
from the user so it says enter your name
so
we can enter in like john and let's say
john is 40 years old so now when i click
enter we're going to have two values and
we'll be able to print them out so it
says hello john you are 40. so that's
sort of the basics of getting input from
the user and again remember what i said
when i use
console.readline it's taking whatever
the user enters and it's storing it as a
variable so this is always going to be a
variable it's always going to get the
information that they enter
as a variable and that's why we had to
store both of those pieces of
information inside of strings but
there's actually a way that we can get
other types of information like numbers
from the user and in the next tutorial
we're going to build a little calculator
game and i'm going to show you guys how
we can actually get numbers from the
user but for now that is sort of the
basics of doing this and you probably
just want to practice with this and
maybe make a little application of your
own
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how to build a basic calculator in
c sharp so we're basically going to
build a little program where the user
can enter in two numbers and then our
program will add them together and spit
out the answer onto the screen so it
should be kind of cool and we're also
going to talk about
getting numbers as input from the user
so this is going to be a pretty cool
tutorial
so down here um before we start building
this i actually want to show you guys
how we can convert a string into a
number and this is a technique that's
going to come in handy for this
application
essentially like if i had a string
that had a number in it so like 45 or
like 45.80
what i could do is i could actually use
a special
method in c sharp that would be able to
convert this
into an actual number and the reason
that's useful is because like if i had
console.writeline like if i had two
strings that had numbers inside of them
like 43
plus
56 if i tried to add these two together
this is just gonna concatenate the
strings so you'll see over here we get
four three five six so it's not adding
the two numbers that are in here
together it's just like concatenating
the strings together so in certain cases
you'll have numbers that are kind of
trapped inside of strings and actually
we're going to have that situation in
this tutorial and so you want to be able
to get the numbers out of there so that
you can like do math with them so i'm
going to show you guys how we can
convert a string into a number so
actually over here why don't we come
down here and we're going to make a
number variable so i'm just going to
make an integer and we'll just call this
num and i'm going to set it equal to
a string so i'm going to set it equal to
a string that has a number in it like
45. you'll see over here c sharp is
yelling at us because
this number is actually a string so it's
not going to be able to be stored inside
of an integer
variable so we need to convert this into
a integer and the way that we can do
that is by typing out
convert like that and all and with a
capital letter and then dot and now we
need to specify what we want to convert
so you'll see over here there's a bunch
of options like 2 in 32 2 and 16 2
double 2 decimal 2 string this little
convert function is basically going to
allow us to convert different values to
other values in our case we want to
convert this to an integer so i'm just
going to say convert dot 2 int
32 and that was one of the options that
we had over here and then i'm going to
make an open and close parentheses
around the actual string so when i do
this this is going to go ahead and
convert
the string inside of here into an
integer and just to note the string that
we put in here has to have a number
inside of it like if this was just
something like that this isn't going to
work we're actually going to get an
error but if i have a number in here
like 45 then this is going to work just
fine so if i was to come down here now i
could actually use this as an integer so
i could say num
plus 6 and now we'll actually be able to
do this math operation so you can see we
get 51 and that's essentially how we can
convert a string
into an integer and just so i can point
this out like if this didn't have a
number inside of it or even if it did
have a number inside of it but the
number had like text next to it this
isn't going to work so
we're actually going to get an error and
you can see the program wasn't able to
run
because
it says down here input string was not
in correct format so that's just
something to keep in mind
and later in the course we're actually
going to talk about how we can
fix something like this and mitigate it
but for now we're just going to assume
that the string is going to be formatted
correctly and i'm just going to exit out
of this exception all right so that's
kind of an explanation of how we can
convert a string into an integer and
we're actually going to be able to use
this in our program so like i said we're
going to build a calculator program
that's going to allow the user to enter
in two numbers and then we'll take those
numbers add them together and print it
out so the first thing i'm going to do
is just print out a prompt so i'm going
to say console.write
and i'm actually just going to use write
and then over here i'm just going to say
enter a number
and now we're prompting the user to
enter a number and what i want to do now
is i want to be able to get the number
that they enter so i'm just going to say
console.readline
[Music]
and this is going to go ahead and
wait it's going to pause the program
until they enter in a
line of text and so what i actually want
to do is i want to store the number that
they enter inside of a variable so i'm
going to create a variable over here and
and we're just going to call it num1 and
i'm going to set it equal to
console.readline
but you'll notice over here we're
getting an error and the problem is that
console.reline is going to give us a
string so console.readline takes
whatever the user enters and turns it
into a string and that's sort of the
value that we have if we want to
eventually add these numbers together
we're not going to be able to use a
string like i showed you before so we're
actually going to have to convert this
into an integer which now we know how to
do so i can just say
convert dot 2 and 32 and i'm going to
surround
console.readline this whole thing with
parentheses so now this whole thing is
surrounded with these parentheses and
it's going to get converted into an
integer and that's basically all we need
to do for that so now i'm going to copy
this and we'll be able to get the second
number so i'm going to come down here
and i'll just say enter
another number and we're going to call
this one num
2.
so now we're prompting the user for a
number we're getting that number and
turning it into an integer
and we're doing the same thing down here
so the last thing we want to do now is
just
print out the answer so i'm going to go
ahead and say console.print lot or
writeline and i'm just going to write
out num1 plus num2
because we converted these guys into
integers we're going to be able to add
them together so let's go ahead and run
this program and we'll see how we did
it says enter a number so let's enter in
a 10
and enter another number so why don't we
enter in a three
and so now it's going to convert both of
those into integers and add them
together and we get 13. so looks like
the program's working out pretty well
there's actually a problem with this
program though if i was trying to add a
integer number with a decimal number so
if i said like four
and over here i put in like a 2.6
this is actually not gonna work so
you'll see the program isn't actually
printing anything out that's because the
program is stalling we didn't enter in a
correct value we entered in a decimal
value and this can't be converted into
an integer so you'll notice that the
program over here
is stalling and basically that's because
we entered in a decimal number so if i
wanted to allow this program to be able
to handle decimal numbers instead of
converting these to integers i'd want to
convert them to doubles so i could
change both of these
to doubles like this double double
and instead of saying convert 2 in 32 i
could say convert dot to double
and same thing down here
and now we should be able to work with
decimal numbers in our program so let's
see if we can do that i want to add 2
and
3.6
and now we're able to add those two
together so in certain circumstances you
might want to have a situation where the
user can only answer in integer numbers
but i think in most cases you'd want to
use doubles just like i did down there
and you can see how easy it is to
convert them into doubles instead of
integers so that's a very basic
calculator and that kind of gives you an
idea of how we can get numbers as input
from a user
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how to build a little mad libs game
in c sharp now if you're not familiar
with mad libs it's basically a game
where you can enter in a bunch of like
random words so maybe like a couple
nouns an adjective an adverb
and you'll take all those random words
and you'll kind of sprinkle them in
throughout a story and generally because
you're entering in random words the
story ends up being like pretty funny so
i actually have an example of a mad lib
over here in my web browser you'll see
it's basically just a little story and
you kind of sprinkle in um different
words like this one is asking for an
adjective or a plural noun or a
celebrity name
so these are pretty fun and i actually
want to show you guys how we can build a
mad libs for ourself in c sharp it's
actually really easy
so down here i have a little program set
up it's basically just writing out this
story so it's writing out roses are red
violets are blue i love you and this is
sort of like a classic little poem
but i think this poem would be a lot
better if we turned it into a mad libs
so how about instead of saying roses are
red we would say roses are and will let
the user choose a color
instead of saying violets are blue we'll
let the user choose a plural noun
and instead of saying i love you we'll
let the user choose a
celebrity that they're going to love and
so we'll basically allow the user to
enter in three random words and then
we'll sprinkle them into our story and
hopefully it'll be pretty funny so let's
think about how we can build a mad libs
essentially what we're going to do is
we're going to have to prompt the user
for input we're going to have to take
that input and store it inside of
variables so let's go ahead and do that
and essentially what we're going to need
is we're going to need three variables
to store the color the plural noun and
the celebrity so i'm actually going to
show you guys
one way that we can do that and we're
actually going to declare these
variables first and then we're going to
give them values so up here i'm just
going to say string and i'm basically
just going to tell c sharp that i'm
going to want to use three variables in
my program so i'm going to want to use
one called color i'm going to want to
use one called
plural noun and i'm going to want to use
one called celebrity and i'm just going
to put a semicolon after this
and if you've been following along with
this course we haven't necessarily been
doing you know exactly this um every
time we were creating variables but this
is one way that we can create a variable
and we're basically just declaring the
variables up here and now down here
we're going to go ahead and give them
values and actually we want to let the
user give these variables their values
because the user is going to be entering
in the color the plural noun and the
celebrity so let's go ahead and write
out some prompts so i'm just going to
say console.write
and in here i'm going to ask the user to
enter a color so i'm just going to say
enter a color
and after i prompt them i want to wait
for them to enter in the color so i'm
just going to say
console.readline and this is basically
going to pause the program and wait for
them to enter in a line of text but i
want to take the line of text that they
enter and store it somewhere so i'm
going to store it inside of this color
variable so i'm just going to say color
which we declared up here and down here
i'm going to give it a value so i'm
going to say color is equal to whatever
the user enters and we can basically do
the same thing for the other two so i'm
going to go ahead and copy this and down
here i'm just going to paste it so i'm
actually going to make some new lines
and so now instead of a color we're
going to want to get a
plural noun and then down here instead
of setting the color variable equal to
whatever they entered now we're going to
store this value inside of the plural
noun variable and then finally down here
instead of asking for the color we're
going to ask for a celebrity
and we're going to store that inside of
the celebrity variable
so now we've prompted the user to enter
in those three things we've stored all
of their responses inside of variables
so the last step is to put those guys
into our story so over here i'm going to
say roses are
and i'm going to use the color
and then instead of just saying plural
noun i'm going to say
plural noun
plus our blue and then finally we'll do
the same for the
celebrity so
i'm taking the variables and i'm
sprinkling them in through this story so
depending on what the user enters this
story is actually going to be a little
bit different so let's go ahead and
we'll run this program and we'll see how
he did so over here it says enter a
color so why don't we enter in like
magenta
enter a plural noun let's do
microwaves
and enter a celebrity why don't we do
like
tom hanks
so all of these values that i entered
are getting stored in the corresponding
variables
and now when i click enter here it
should print all of them out inside of
our madlibs
so i click enter and it says roses are
magenta microwaves are blue i love tom
hanks so we actually built a fully
functioning mad libs right i can go in i
can enter in any values that i would
want and those are going to get
sprinkled into the mad lib now over here
we built the very simple mad libs right
this was you know essentially three
inputs and then we put them into a very
simple poem but you can see how you
could use this same technique in order
to ask the user to enter in like maybe
10 or 20 different words and you can
make a way more complex story down there
so essentially with very few lines of
code i mean this is probably you know 10
lines of code we were able to write out
an entire mad lib in c sharp
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about arrays in c sharp a lot
of times when we're writing programs in
c sharp we're going to be dealing with
all types of data a lot of times we're
going to be dealing with large amounts
of data and one way that we can manage
and keep track of the data in our
programs is by using variables but the
one problem with variables is that they
can only store a single value so i can
create a variable like an integer
variable or a string variable but i
could only store one integer or one
string inside of that variable container
and a lot of times if we're dealing with
huge amounts of information we're not
going to want to have to create like
hundreds or thousands of variables so
it's actually another container another
type of data structure that we can use
in c sharp which is called an array and
an array is basically a structure that
allows us to hold multiple pieces of
information in the same container so
unlike a variable that can only hold one
value an array can hold multiple values
so you could hold 10 or 100 or a
thousand or even a million values inside
of an array so a good way to think of an
array is just a collection of individual
variables right so an array can hold
like 20 different values that you would
normally have to put inside of a
variable so i'm going to show you guys
how we can create arrays we'll talk
about sort of the basics of using them
and i'll kind of get you guys up to
speed with using arrays in c sharp so
down here in my program i'm going to go
ahead and create an array and remember
an array is just a container that can
hold a bunch of pieces of information so
we create an array very similar to how
we create a variable the first thing we
have to do is specify the type of
information or the type of data that the
array is going to hold so we can use all
the basic data types string in double
boolean we can use all those things in
our case let's make an array of integers
so i'm just going to say int
and then i'm going to type a space now
whenever we're creating an array in c
sharp we always need to let c sharp know
that so the way that we can tell c that
we want to make a variable instead of an
array is by making an open and closed
square bracket and that's going to
signify that this is going to be an
array and then over here i can type the
name of the array that i want to create
so i can give this array a name so why
don't we just call this like
lucky numbers we'll create an array
that's going to store a list of lucky
numbers in order to give this array some
information there's actually a couple
different ways we can assign values to
arrays i'm going to show you guys all
the ways in this tutorial but the most
basic way is to just make an open and
closed curly bracket and then inside of
here we can start typing out the values
that we want to put inside of our array
so i can just start typing out some
numbers and we'll be able to store them
all in the same container so over here
i'm just going to type like 4 8 15 16
23 42. so i'm just typing out a bunch of
different integers and you'll notice
that i have one value here and then i
separate it with a comma and then i can
put another value so all of these would
be considered elements inside of the
array so i would say like four is the
first element in the array eight is the
second element in the array and we can
delineate the elements using these
commas and essentially now we have a
container we have this lucky numbers
container which is able to store all of
these values and this makes it really
easy for us to manage and maintain large
amounts of information so i mean over
here i only have like maybe six numbers
but if i wanted i could put hundreds or
thousands or even millions of values
inside of one of these arrays and
they're extremely useful so now that
we've looked at how we can create an
array let's talk about how we can access
the individual elements inside of an
array right because this array is going
to be no use to us unless we can
actually get access to each of these
values so i'm going to show you guys how
we can do that and i'm just going to do
a console.writeline so we'll just print
out a particular value onto the screen
so if i want to access a particular
value i can just type out the name of
the array so in our case lucky numbers
and then i want to make an open and
closed square bracket and inside of this
square bracket i want to give a number
so i'm basically going to specify the
index of the element that i want to
print out or the index of the element
that i want to access so let's say i
wanted to access this element 4 right
here it's the first element in the array
i'm gonna put a zero here so this four
element is at the zeroth position it's
at the zero index inside of the array so
now when i run my program you'll see
we're printing out four so we're
printing out that first element in the
array
and so the way that we index these array
elements is starting with zero so if
you've been following along with this
course you'll know that this is the same
way we index strings so i would say that
four is at index position 0 in the array
8 is at index position 1 15 is at index
position 2
16 at 3 etc so we start counting in
other words we start the indexing at
zero so over here i could say like lucky
numbers 2 and now we're going to get 0 1
2. we're going to get this 15 back
so we'll be printing out that 15. you
can see over there so essentially when
we access an element in the array like
this it's a lot like we're accessing a
variable and it's actually you can think
of each one of these elements in here as
their own kind of separate variables and
you can do everything with them that you
could do with normal variables so
another thing we could do would be to
update one of these elements so for
example if i wanted i could go ahead and
change one of the values over here so
let's say we wanted to change this
element we wanted to change eight well i
could actually just say
lucky numbers and i'll make an open and
close square bracket i'm going to put
the index of the element that i want to
change so this 8 is going to be at index
position 1
and i can give this a new value so we
can give this a value of like 900. now
if i print out lucky numbers 1 you'll
see that the value will have updated
so now we get the value of 900 instead
of just getting the value of eight so
i'm able to update these i can really
you know do anything that i could do
with a normal variable with each one of
these individual values and that's
pretty cool so in addition to creating a
an array of integers i could also create
like an array of strings so why don't we
do that i'm going to make an array of
strings
and i'm just going to call this friends
so this will be like a list of maybe my
friends or something and i'm going to
show you guys another way that we can
create an array like this so
you'll see up here right away i was
giving this array a bunch of values so
right off the bat when i created it i
was populating this array with a bunch
of information but a lot of times when
you create arrays in c sharp you're not
going to know exactly what elements you
want to put inside of them so if you
don't know exactly what elements need to
go in here up front we can just create
an empty array so i could actually just
say
string friends and i'm just going to set
this equal to new string and then i'm
going to type in open and close square
bracket and inside of these square
brackets i need to put a number and this
number is going to tell c sharp how many
elements we want this array to be able
to hold so if we create an array like
this and we don't give it elements like
we did up here we still need to tell c
sharp how many elements this array can
hold we need to basically tell c sharp
how big we want to make the array so
over here if i put 10 like that that
means that this friends array is going
to be able to hold 10 values if i put 3
that means the friends array is going to
be able to hold 3 values so why don't we
put 5
and down here what i can do is i can
populate this array with information so
i could say like friends
zero is equal to and then i could type
out the name of a friend so i could say
like
gym
and then i could do the same thing for
the other one so i could say like
friends one is equal to kelly et cetera
so i could do that for each element
inside of this array and individually
populate it and this is actually going
to come in handy in a lot of situations
and as we go forward in the course i'm
going to show you guys how we could do
something like that in a future tutorial
but for now just know that this is
another way that we can create an array
all right so really that is the basics
of using arrays arrays are extremely
simple but they're extremely powerful
it's essentially just a type of
container much like a variable but
unlike a variable it can store multiple
pieces of information and again all of
those pieces of information need to be
of the same type just like we have up
here
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about methods in c-sharp now a
method is basically just a little block
of code where we can perform a specific
task so a lot of times when you're
writing programs in c sharp you'll have
like a few lines of code maybe like five
or ten lines which are performing a
specific task like the whole idea of
having those lines in the program is
that they're going to do a certain thing
so what we can actually do is we can
create something called a method which
will allow us to take all that code and
put it into its own little container and
then we want to execute it and we want
to perform the task that that code is
going to carry out we can just call that
method and we'll be able to reuse it in
different spots in our program so i'm
going to show you guys exactly how to
create a method and we're going to talk
exactly about what it does and how
they're useful so
what i want to do in this tutorial is i
want to create a method which is going
to say hi to the user so the task of
this method is going to be to say hi
to whoever is using the program so what
i want to do when i create a new method
is i actually want to come down out here
outside of these curly brackets so
believe it or not this line of code up
here where it says static void main this
is actually a method inside of our
program so like i said a method is just
a container or it's sort of like a block
where we can put
code that's going to perform a specific
task and this main method is very
special because this is the method that
gets executed when we run our program so
any code that i type down here in this
main method gets executed when i run my
program but in addition to writing this
main method we can also define other
methods that are going to work a little
bit differently but it's the same idea
we're encapsulating a bunch of code
inside of its own little container so in
order to create a new method i want to
first go outside of this main method so
this main method is all the code that i
have highlighted you can see it's
delineated with this open and closed
curly bracket so i'm going to come down
here below this and we can actually
create a new method so when i create my
method i need to tell
c sharp a couple different things and
the first thing we need to do is say a
keyword static
and i'm actually going to talk a lot
more about what static means in later
tutorials and as of right now
it's really not super important as to
what this is doing again i will explain
what this is but for now just know that
we have to put static here if we're
going to put our method alongside this
main method after i say static i need to
specify something called a return type
now these methods are awesome because
they can perform specific tasks for us
and one of the things they can do is
they can actually give us back
information so if i was to run one of
these methods it can actually give
information back to me and you'll see
how to do that we're going to talk more
about return types in the next tutorial
but for now i'm just going to say void
and that basically means that this
method isn't going to return any
information so this is kind of like the
simplest method that we can create all
right so after i say void i want to give
this method a name now remember methods
are generally going to be performing a
specific task so you want to name the
method based off of the task that it's
performing our method in this tutorial
is basically just going to say hi to the
user so i'm just going to call this say
hi and generally in c sharp when we're
creating a method we're going to create
it using a capital letter for the name
so you can see i named it just like that
you can also see up here main was named
with a capital letter and that's just a
naming convention that's not necessary
but
a lot of people are going to do that
then what we want to put in here is an
open and close parentheses and then an
open and closed curly bracket over there
and i'm just going to go ahead and
indent in for into this curly bracket
any code that we put inside of these two
curly brackets is going to be considered
part of the method so any code that we
put in here will be run when we call our
method so i can essentially write all
the code in here to perform the task
that the method is designed to carry out
remember this method is just going to
say hi to the user so i can basically
just print something out onto the screen
i'll say console.writeline
and why don't we just come over here and
say
hello user our
method down here has one line of code
and methods can have as many lines of
code as you want i mean you could have
i'd say most methods have anywhere from
five to ten lines of code but you can
have more or less than that it doesn't
really matter in my case though i just
have a very simple method so it's going
to be one line of code all right so now
what i want to do is go ahead and run my
program and we'll see what happens so
i'm just going to click this start
button
and you'll see over here nothing got
printed out so even though we created
our new method and we put a line of code
inside this method
it didn't execute this line of code in
other words this line of code never got
executed by c sharp
here's the reason
when we create a method this code isn't
going to get run automatically
only the code that's inside of this main
method is going to get run when we run
our program so because this code wasn't
inside of this main method it didn't get
run now if i want to execute all of the
code inside of this say hi function i
can actually do something called calling
it so i can call
this method basically what that means is
c sharp is going to go over to the
method execute all of the code inside of
it so the way i can call the method is
just by typing out its name i can just
say say hi and i can make an open and
close parentheses and then now we should
be able to execute this code so when i
run my program now
you'll see we're printing out hello
users so the code inside the method got
executed now essentially what's
happening is whenever c sharp sees this
line of code what it does is
it jumps over it goes over to this say
hi method and it's going to go through
and execute all of the code inside of
there then when it's done executing the
code inside of here it's going to come
back and it's going to move on to the
next line of code in the main method
that's essentially what's happening so
this is extremely useful and there's
going to be a lot of circumstances where
you're going to want to have methods
that are doing different things and
you're going to want to have all of that
code inside of its own single container
but this is really just scratching the
surface of what we can do with these
methods and i want to show you guys
another thing we can do we can actually
give these methods information
inside of this say hi function i could
actually specify that this say high
function should take in some information
and this is what we would call
parameters or arguments and a parameter
is basically just a value that gets
passed into a method so it's a value
that we would give to this method and
then it could use that value to perform
its task better or do something
and the way that we can specify a
parameter is by coming in here into the
open and close parentheses and i can
just basically specify what type of
information i want to accept so let's
say that instead of saying hello user we
wanted this method to say hi to a
particular person well over here i could
specify string name
and now when i write out this line
string name i'm basically saying that
the say hi method needs to take as a
parameter as an argument
one value which is going to be a name
then what i can do is i can come down
here and i can print out hello
name
you'll see we're getting an error up
here when we're calling this method
that's because i didn't include a name
when i called it so now whenever i call
this method i have to pass it a string
so i'm going to pass it the string mic
and essentially what's going to happen
is this string mic that i passed this
method is going to get stored inside of
this string variable inside of this name
variable and then i'm just going to
print it out so now we should be
printing out hello
mic
and you can see we get that right there
so that's one cool way that we can run
these methods and the other cool thing
about methods is that i can call this
code as many times as i want it so i
could call it again and again and each
time pass in a different name
so
we'll pass in mike john and tom and now
each time we call this the method is
going to do something slightly different
so it's going to say hi
to someone different so now it's saying
whoops
now it's saying hello mike hello john
hello
tom so really what we're doing is we're
able to write this code in one place and
then we're able to reuse it continually
inside of our program and that's another
reason why methods are awesome
in addition to just passing in one
parameter we could also specify that
this should take two parameters so
instead of just a name why don't we also
pass in an integer age and then down
here we can add the agent so i can say
hello name
you are and then we'll just print out
the age
so now when i call these methods up here
you'll see we're getting more errors
because i have to give these values so i
can say like 33
and
12. and now when i run my program it's
going to be able to handle that so this
method is now printing out both the name
and the age that we passed in and really
you can pass anything you want into
these methods you can pass
strings ants doubles you can even pass
things like arrays it doesn't really
matter you know any value
that you want to work with you can pass
into here as long as you can specify it
um over there so that's kind of the
basics of working with methods now i
will say um you'll hear most of the time
people are going to call these methods
you'll also hear people refer to these
as functions
methods and functions are essentially
the same thing there is a small
difference
just in the definition but generally you
can use the word method and the word
function interchangeably and you'll hear
a lot of people call these functions you
also hear a lot of people call them
methods but generally in c sharp like
the official term would be
a method so that's really why methods
are useful you can kind of see you know
we were essentially able to reuse all
the code that we wrote down here so i
can reuse it and give it different
information and it'll do different
things
now in the next video i'm going to talk
to you guys about this value over here
which is going to be the return value so
in addition to passing information into
methods methods can also pass
information back to the callers and
we're going to talk about that in the
next tutorial
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how to use return statements in
c-sharp methods
so in c-sharp a method is basically just
a little
block of code which is designed to
perform a specific task
and in the last tutorial i showed you
guys how we could create a very simple
method that would say hi to the user
in this tutorial i want to show you guys
how we can use another feature of c
sharp methods which is the return
keyword and basically what we can do is
inside of these methods we can return
values back to the collars so i'm gonna
show you guys how this works and we'll
kind of get an idea of what this is and
what it does so down here in my program
you'll notice i have my main method over
here and i'm actually gonna create
another method so i'm gonna come down
here below the main method and i want to
create a method which is going to cube a
number so when you cube a number you
basically take it to the third power so
2 raised to the third power is the same
as 2 times 2 times 2 right so we would
say that this is 2
cubed so what i want to do is actually
create a method that will
take as a parameter so take it as an
argument one number and then it'll cube
it and it'll actually return that number
back to the collar so this is going to
be kind of cool
so remember whenever we're creating a
method we need to say
static
and like i said i'm going to explain
what static is and what it does later in
the tutorial but for now just know that
whenever you're creating a method
here next to this main method because
main is such a special method
i'm also going to use this static
keyword for the new method that i create
then the next thing i need to tell c
sharp is going to be the return type and
in the last tutorial we used this void
return type which basically meant we
weren't going to return any information
but
now what i want to do is i want to
actually specify a particular data type
that we're going to return so in our
case why don't we just say we're going
to return an integer so now what i want
to do is give this method a name so i'm
just going to say
cube so it's going to be called cube
because it's cubing a number i'm going
to make an open and close parenthesis
and open and close curly bracket
inside of this parentheses what i want
to do is specify a parameter so this
cube method is going to take one
parameter and it's going to be an
integer and we're just going to call it
num
so num is going to be the number that
they pass in and eventually what we're
going to want to do is we're going to
want to return to them the value of num
cubed so what i can do down here is i
can make an integer and i'm just going
to say int and we'll call it result and
i want to set result equal to the cubed
value of num in order to get that we can
just say num times num
times num
and so now this variable result is going
to have num times num times num stored
in it in other words it's going to have
the num cubed stored inside of it now
what i want to do is use a special
keyword in c sharp called return
and whenever we put this keyword inside
of a method this is basically going to
tell the method that we want to return
a piece of information back to the
caller and also this return keyword is
going to break us out of the method so
over here what i can do is i can just
say return result so i'm going to go
ahead and return this result variable
that we just created back to the caller
now let's go up here in our main method
and actually call this method so what i
want to do is i'm just going to call it
so i'm going to say cube and i'll pass
in a number let's pass in five
so now i'm gonna go ahead and run my
program and we'll see what happens so
you'll see my program ran but i mean
nothing really happened right there was
no output there really you know there
was no errors but really nothing
happened here's the thing though if i
was to come over here and say
console.writeline
if i printed out
this method in other words if i print it
out calling this method you'll see we're
actually going to print out result we're
actually going to print out the value of
cubing these numbers so over here i just
said console.writeline
and inside of here i'm printing out
cube5
now when i run my program you'll see
we're printing out 125
basically what happened was when i used
this return keyword down here that
returned the value back over to this
method so then when i called the method
it was actually given the value of 125
and that is extremely useful that's
basically a way that we can get a piece
of information back from a method just
to further illustrate this point i want
to create another example so down here
i'm going to make an
integer and i'm just going to call it
cubednumber and i'm going to set it
equal to
cube5.
so i'm actually setting this variable
equal to cube5. now i could print out
cubed number and you'll see we're going
to get that value 125 back and so that's
essentially what we're able to do we're
able to return a value back from this
method in addition to returning an
integer we could return anything so if i
wanted i could return a string
or a double
or i could even return like an array of
doubles right something like that so you
can really return any value that you
want back from these methods but
returning information can be extremely
useful and you're definitely going to
want to use it inside of your c-sharp
methods
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about if statements in c sharp
now an if statement is basically a
special structure in our program which
will allow our program to respond to
different situations so essentially with
if statements our programs can become
smarter and i want to show you guys some
examples of if statements and we're
going to kind of look at how we can
create and use if statements in our
programs now over here i have this
little text file open and one of the
cool things about if statements is that
as human beings we encounter them every
single day so over here i have some
examples of if statements that you might
see on a daily basis so up here it says
i wake up if i'm hungry
i eat breakfast so this is an example of
an if statement essentially an if
statement has two parts it has a
condition which is right here and then
it has an action that gets executed when
the condition is true so our condition
up here is if i'm hungry now this
condition is either true or false it can
only have two possible values true or
false you're either hungry or you're not
if you are hungry in other words if this
condition is true up here then you're
going to eat breakfast but if you're not
if this condition is
then you're just going to move on and
that is the essence of an if statement
we check a condition if the condition is
true then we'll perform an action if the
condition is false then we'll move on
and we won't perform that action so just
like you're able to make a decision
about whether or not you're hungry and
whether or not you should eat breakfast
we can use these in our programs to do
the same thing to make decisions there's
another one down here that says i look
at my phone if it's about to die
i charge it so again this is a condition
it's either true or false if it's true
if your phone is about to die then you
charge it otherwise we're just going to
move on here's a little bit of a more
complex if statement it says i leave my
house
if it's cloudy i bring an umbrella so
again here's our condition if it's true
then we're going to bring the umbrella
if it's false though now we're going to
do something else so up here when the
condition was false we just moved on but
now if this condition's false otherwise
we're gonna bring our sunglasses so
we're gonna do
something else and these are just some
basic if statements but i just kind of
wanted to give you guys an idea of what
these were before we implement them in
our programs so we can do essentially
the same thing but we can allow our
programs to make decisions so when
certain conditions are true we can do
certain things and if they're false then
we can do other things so let's go back
over to our program dot c sharp and
you'll see down here i'm just in my main
method and i'm going to show you guys
how we can use some if statements so
before we do any if statements i'm
actually going to create a variable so
this is going to be a boolean variable
and i'm just going to call it is male
and this variable is going to tell us
whether or not somebody is a male so i'm
a male so i'm going to set this equal to
true
so now we have this boolean variable is
male and it has a value of true
now what i want to do is i want to
create an if statement and we can
actually create an if statement based
off of this ismail variable so let's say
that we have this variable in our
program we're working with it and we
want to do something when the person is
male so inside of our program when the
person's male when this variable is true
we want to be able to do something i can
use an if statement to check that i can
come down here and say if and i'm going
to make an open and closed parenthesis
and an open enclosed curly bracket and
this is sort of the general outline of
an if statement in our program now
inside of this parentheses i want to
specify a condition so just like over in
that text file we had some conditions
like if i'm hungry or if my phone's
about to die
inside of these parentheses we want to
specify a condition
now this condition needs to be a true or
a false value right if i'm hungry that
was our condition before that's true or
false right it can only have one of two
values if my phone's about to die is
true or false it can only have one of
two values so inside of this parentheses
we need to put a condition which is
basically just going to be a true or a
false value so in my case i want to
check to see if the person is male so i
can say if
is male and if this variable is true
then we're going to be able to execute
the code that we put down here so why
don't we just write out
console.writeline
and we'll just write out
you are male so we're writing out
console.writeline if the variable is
male is equal to true so let's go ahead
and run this program and you'll see over
here it's printing out you are male so
our program was smart enough to
determine whether or not someone was
male if i was to set this equal to false
and now i went to run my program when i
run the program you'll notice that
nothing is going to get printed out
because
the variable was false so this line of
code down here only gets executed when
this condition up here in these
parentheses
is true
so that's how we can use a basic if
statement but let's say that when ismail
was false we wanted to do something else
so let's say even if this variable was
false we wanted to try and do something
else well i can actually use another
keyword in c sharp which is called else
so i can say else and open and close
curly bracket
and then down here we can write out
another line of code so i'm actually
just going to copy this guy and down
here we're going to write out you are
not male so when they are male we'll
tell them that and when they're not male
when ismail is false we'll also tell
them that so
ismail is false right now and it should
tell us that so it should tell us you
are not male
essentially what we've done now is we've
created a program that is able to
respond to the value of a variable so
this program can respond to this
variable right if ismail is true
then we're going to print out you are
mail if ismail is false then we're going
to print out you are not male so our
program is smart our program can adapt
and adjust what it's doing depending on
the value of a variable and therein lies
the essence of if statements if
statements allow our programs to make
decisions and to do different things
when different conditions are met but
this is a very simple if statement in
fact this is probably like the simplest
if else statement that we could write
i'm going to make this a little bit more
complex and we're going to go ahead and
we're going to create another variable
so i'm going to come up here and make
another boolean and i'm just going to
call it is tall
and this is tall variable again is going
to store a true or a false value so why
don't we set both of these equal to true
just to start off so this is tall
variable is going to
tell us whether or not someone is tall
so this will determine if they're like
tall or short
and down here let's say that instead of
just checking to see if they are male we
also wanted to check to see if they're
tall so i can say if is male
and i can actually use another
operator in c sharp and it's called the
and operator so i can say two ampersands
like this and this stands for and and
basically when we use this and operator
it allows me to write two conditions in
the same condition block so it allows me
to not only check to see if they're male
but i could also check to see if they're
tall
so now this is saying if is male and
is tall
so now not only does ismail have to be
true but is tall also has to be true
for this whole thing to be true so if
one of these guys was false then this
whole thing would be false so now down
here i could say you are
a tall
male
right and then down here instead of
saying you are not male
i could instead say you are
either not male or not tall or both
right because if this code gets executed
it means
one or both of the conditions up here is
false so let me demonstrate this you'll
see over here both of these are set to
true and when i run my program it's
going to be able to respond to that so
you'll see it says you are a tall male
because both of those were true
but let's say i set one of these to
false so i said is male equal to false
well now because one of these guys is
false this whole thing is going to be
false so we're going to print this out
down here so now when i run the program
you'll see it's printing out you are
either not male or not tall or both so
it's able to respond to those two
variables in our program in addition to
using this and operator we can also use
another operator which is called or
and or does the same thing as and except
it's a little bit different so or will
allow us to check two conditions but
this time only one of these conditions
has to be true
for this whole thing to be true so we
would read this as if
is male or
is tall so they either have to be male
or they have to be tall or they can be
both and then we'll be able to execute
this code right here but if both of
these guys are false then we're going to
go down here and execute this code so
let me just demonstrate this really
quick and i'm not going to bother
changing the text here you guys kind of
hopefully get what's going on so even
though false and true are both up here
so even though one of these guys is
false
we're still going to be able to
print out you are a tall male but if i
was to make both of these false
now we're gonna end up printing out you
are either not male or not tall or both
which again i realize isn't the right
text for that but you can just kind of
understand what's going on so it says
you are either not male or not tall or
both so that's the difference between
and and or when we use and here
both of these conditions have to be true
so both of these variables would have to
be true for this whole thing to be true
and for us to execute that code
when we use or
only one of them has to be true so this
could be false or
this could be false but one of them has
to be true for the whole thing to be
true and that's really the difference so
i'm going to turn this back to and i
want to show you guys some other stuff
we can do so right now we're able to
check the condition where they're male
and they're tall but there's also a
couple different scenarios in addition
to that for example let's say that
they're male but they're not tall
well what if we wanted to do something
when they were male but they were not
tall so if they're like a short male i
can actually use another keyword another
reserve word in c sharp which is called
else if
and i can just type out else if like
this i can make an open and close
parentheses and an open and close curly
bracket and then i'm just going to make
a new line so essentially what i did
here was i added in elsif
and then you can see this else basically
goes after it when i use else if it
allows me to check another condition so
if this condition up here is false i can
actually come down here and check
another condition so we wanted to check
to see if they were male and they were
not tall so i could say
else if is male
and now i need to figure out how i can
specify not tall so remember this
variable is tall will tell us if they're
tall or not if i wanted to find out if
they're not tall i could just say
exclamation point
is tall and this is going to read as not
tall
not is tall this exclamation point here
is what's known as the negation operator
and this will basically
negate the
condition so over here i have is tall if
this was true
then when i put this exclamation point
here it's going to make it false if this
was false when i put this exclamation
point here it's going to make it true so
this whole thing is going to be true
when the person is not tall and so now
this is essentially checking to see if
they're male and they're not tall
so down here we could write another
message so i could basically say like
you are a short male
because they're male but they're not
tall
and finally i'm going to make one more
else if so i'm just going to come down
here and there's one more thing that we
want to check so i also want to check to
see if they're tall but they're not male
right so over here we're checking if
they're male and they're tall over here
we're checking to see if they're male
and they're not tall
down here i want to check to see if
they're not male
and
they are tall so this is saying else if
not male and is tall so down here we can
put another little message and i'm just
going to basically say like you are
not a male
but you are tall so this is essentially
just saying exactly what it is you're
not male but you are
tall
and then down here for this else
remember this code now is only going to
get executed when none of these
conditions up here are true so now down
here we can just say you are not male
and not tall
all right so let me walk you guys
through this one more time up here i'm
saying if is male and is tall so this
condition is only going to be true when
both of these are true
and then if this is true we're going to
come down here and execute this code
we're going to say you are a tall male
but if this is false we're going to come
down here to this elsif and we're going
to check another condition
so only when this is false are we going
to check this condition down here
and we're basically going to check to
see if they're male and they're not tall
and i'm using this negation operator
here and if that's true then we're going
to tell them that we're going to print
that out then we're going to check to
see if they're not male and they're tall
and we'll print out a message for that
and then finally we'll say you are not
male and not tall
so let's go ahead and run our program
and you'll see both of these guys are
going to be set to true initially and
we'll try all these different
combinations so both of them are set to
true i'm going to run the program and it
says you are a tall male so our program
was smart enough to be able to respond
to the value of these two variables so
now let's set ismail equal to false so
i'm going to come down here and we'll
just say false and now essentially this
is going to be able to respond so i can
run my program now and you'll see it's
printing out you are not male but you
are tall so it was able to respond to
that different value now we'll set
ismail back equal to true and we'll set
is tall equal to false and now we should
get a appropriate response so it says
you are a short male and finally if
these are both equal to false then again
the program's gonna be able to respond
to that so it's gonna say you are not
male and not tall awesome so essentially
what we did with these if statements was
we allowed our program to respond to
different values right our program was
able to make decisions based off the
information
that it was given and this is really
just scratching the surface of if
statements you'll see over here we're
using these boolean variables right but
there's actually another way that we can
specify these conditions and it's using
something called comparisons and in the
next tutorial i'm going to talk to you
guys all about comparisons about how to
use them and it's basically just another
way that these if statements can come in
handy
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys some more about if statements
more specifically we're going to be
talking about comparisons so inside of
an if statement we can actually compare
two values and depending on you know the
result of the comparison we can do
different things this is going to be
kind of cool
and essentially what i want to do in
this tutorial is i want to build a
method and this method is basically
going to be a max method so the max
method um if you're not familiar is
basically a method where we can give it
two numbers and it'll tell us which one
is bigger so we're going to write a
method that takes two parameters as
input num1 and num2 and then we'll
basically be able to return whichever is
bigger so i'm going to go down here and
i'm going to go below this main method
and we're going to create another method
so i'm just going to say static and i'm
going to want this to return an integer
so why don't we just say that it's going
to return an integer and i'm going to
call it get max and then i'm going to
make an open and close parentheses and
open and close curly bracket so
get max is going to take one or two
parameters so we're going to take an
integer num1 and then we're also going
to take another integer num 2.
basically the job of this method is to
figure out which of these two numbers is
bigger and then return it to the caller
so let's go ahead and set this up i'm
actually going to create a variable so
i'm just going to make an integer i'll
call it result
and i'm not actually going to give this
a value yet so we're going to end up
giving this a value inside of the method
and then down here i'm going to return
result so i'm just going to return this
variable
and inside of this method now our goal
is to figure out which number is bigger
right so inside of this method we don't
know if num1 is bigger or num2 is bigger
we have no idea right all we know is
that we have two numbers here that we
can work with so
what we want to do is use an if
statement and an if statement will allow
us to do something when a certain
condition is true and do something else
when a certain condition is false so i'm
going to make an if statement i'm just
going to say if and i'm going to make an
open and close parentheses and an open
and closed curly bracket so this is like
the sort of outline structure for our if
statement now inside of these
parentheses i need to put a condition
and remember a condition is a true or
false value
in the previous tutorial we were using
booleans as our conditions so i had a
boolean like is male and another one is
tall and we use that as the conditions
for our if statements but here's the
thing we don't necessarily have any
booleans to work with right all we can
work with here are these two integers so
what i can do is i can actually use
something called a comparison so i can
compare the two numbers so i could
actually say like if num1
is greater than num2
and essentially what i'm doing here is
i'm comparing the two values but
remember inside of these parentheses we
need a condition we need a true or a
false
value but actually the cool thing is
that when this when we do this
comparison this is going to resolve down
to a true or a false value right so num1
is either going to be greater than num2
or it's not there's only two possible
scenarios with this comparison right
either it's true and num1 is greater
than num2 or it's false and num2 is
greater than or equal to num1 right so
really this gets resolved down to a true
or a false value anyway so these
comparisons can be
super useful inside of our parentheses
now inside of this actual if block
if num1 is indeed greater than num2 then
we can just set result equal to num1 and
then i'm going to make an else statement
down here and i'll just say else
and i'm just going to say
result is equal to
num2
so
if num1 is greater than num2 then we'll
make result num1 otherwise we'll make it
num2 and then down here we're just
returning result so this method is
basically done we have everything that
we need we should be able to figure out
which number is bigger so let's go back
up here to our main method and i'm going
to call this and i'm actually going to
print out the answer so i'm just going
to say
console.rt
and then inside of these parentheses
we're going to call it so i'll just say
get max
and why don't we pass this
2 and 10.
so ideally we're going to get a 10 back
because 10 is the bigger number so let's
go ahead and run this program
and you'll see we're getting that 10
back no problem
so let's now see if
it's going to work when the first number
is the bigger one and hopefully it does
so we should get 20 which we do so this
method is working out and you can see we
were able to use this comparison in
order to figure it out so
that's awesome and this is pretty cool
but i'm going to get rid of this let's
up the ante a little bit let's make this
a little bit more difficult
let's say instead of
two numbers we wanted to be able to
compare three numbers so we wanted this
max function to be able to tell us the
maximum of three separate numbers
well in here i can just specify another
parameter so i can say num3
and now down here not only do we have to
figure out two of them but we have to
figure out three of them so of these
three numbers
which one is bigger now we're going to
want to use another if statement so i'm
going to go ahead and and this time i'll
make that same if statement essentially
and
now we need a condition so
not only do we need to check to see if
num1 is greater than num2 but we also
have to check to see if it's greater
than num3 so i'm going to say if num1 is
greater than or equal to num2
and so i'm using this and operator num1
is greater than or equal to
num3
then down here we can set result
equal to num1 because
if num1 is bigger than num2 and it's
also bigger than num3 then we know it's
the biggest one right so we can just go
ahead and return that but let's say that
this isn't the case i want to do another
one so i'm going to say else if and
we'll make a another condition down here
so i'm basically just going to say else
if
num2 is greater than or equal to num1
and num2
is greater than or equal to num3
right so if num2 is bigger than num1 and
it's bigger than num3 then num2 is the
biggest so we'll say result is equal to
num2
finally then we can just say else and
down here we can specify the else so
i'm just going to go ahead and set
result
equal to num3
because if num1 is not the biggest and
remember we checked that up here and
num2 is not the biggest which we check
down here then num3 is going to be the
biggest so let's go ahead and test this
out so now we need to include another
number so i'm going to put like a 4 in
here so we should get back this 20
because that's the biggest number
and you can see we do
let's try it with the other places so
let's make this last one here we'll make
this a 40. so this is going to be the
biggest
and we'll see if this works which it
does so this get max method seems to be
working out pretty well
now down here you'll notice when i
compared the two numbers i'm using these
like greater than or equal to's or
before i just use a greater than these
are called comparison operators and
these comparison operators can be used
to compare different values so i can use
uh greater than
less than
greater than or equal to
less than or equal to i can also use
equal to and this double equals a
special because it's going to allow us
to compare these two numbers so this
isn't used for assignment like down here
we use the single equals for assignment
so i assigned the value of num1 to
result up here i'm comparing the values
so i'm basically checking to see if the
value of num1 is equivalent or equal to
the value of num
2.
and then we can also use one more which
is going to be not equals and this is
going to be the opposite so this will
say
num1 not equal to num2 so that's
essentially how we can use comparisons
and you can also in addition to numbers
you could also compare like
characters so i could compare like two
characters
um you know basically like that and
that's going to work out just fine so
these comparisons are extremely useful
and i would say that a lot of times when
you're using if statements you're going
to be using comparisons just like that
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how to build a four function
calculator
in c sharp now if you've been following
along with this course you'll know that
in the beginning of the course we
actually created a very simple
calculator and essentially the
calculator would let the user enter in
two numbers and it would take those
numbers and sort of add them together
and then print out the answer right it's
very simple in this tutorial we're going
to take that calculator to the next
level so we're going to actually allow
the user to enter in two numbers and
they're also going to be able to specify
an operator so they'll be able to
specify whether whether or not they want
to add the numbers subtract the numbers
multiply or divide the numbers so it's
going to be pretty cool
and let's go ahead and get into it so
the first thing we want to do is we want
to be able to get all the information
from the user
so i'm basically just going to be
printing out prompts and then we'll be
storing the values that the user enters
inside of variables so the first thing
i'll do is just
print out a prompt basically prompting
them to um
enter in some information and actually
i'm just going to use write instead of
write line
so i'll say
enter a
number
and they'll enter their first number
and then what we want to do is we want
to get that number and store it inside
of a variable so let's store this inside
of a double so i'm just going to call
this num1
and i'm just going to set it equal to
console.readline
but remember whenever we use
console.readline this is going to give
us a string back so if i want to store
this value inside of a double over here
i'm actually going to have to use
something called convert so i'm going to
say
convert dot
to
double and i'm going to place
console.readline inside of this methods
parentheses so i'm going to pass this in
as an argument as a parameter to the
convert.2double method that's
essentially what's happening there and
i'm basically just going to copy this
line
and i'm going to paste it down here
because we're gonna do the same exact
thing for the second number so i'm gonna
say
num2 is equal to convert to double
console.readline so we're getting the
first number and we're getting the
second number and we're storing them in
the num1 variable and the num2 variable
now one more thing i want to do is i
want to get the operator
so i'm basically just just going to say
console.write
and over here i'll just say
operator so
this is going to be like a plus sign a
minus sign division sign uh
multiplication time etc
and then down here we can just make this
a string so i'm going to say string op
for operator is going to be equal to
console.readline
so
basically what i'm doing is i'm getting
the first number i'm converting it to a
double
i'm getting the operator plus minus
division whatever i'm getting the second
number so now at this point in my
program i should have all the
information that i need so the question
becomes how can we perform the operation
in other words we have the two numbers
great but how can we figure out what the
user entered in right how do we figure
out what op is telling us to do
we can use an if statement so i'm going
to use an if statement i'm just going to
say if i want to make an open and close
parenthesis and open and close
curly bracket and down here we want to
check a condition so essentially what i
want to do is i want to check to see if
the operator is equal to a plus sign so
i can say if op
is equal to
plus sign right
if the operator is equal to a plus sign
then we know for a fact that they're
trying to add the numbers and i'm
actually just going to print that out
down here so i can say console.write
and we're basically just print out
num1 plus num2 and actually i'm going to
do rightline here
all right so if it's a plus sign then
we're going to be able to add the
numbers but what if it's not a plus sign
well i want to check another condition
here so i'm going to say
else if and we'll check another one
we basically want to check to see if the
operator is equal to a minus sign if the
operator is equal to a minus sign now
we're going to do the same thing we did
up here it's just that we're going to
subtract the number so i'm going to say
num1 minus num2
we can do the same thing for
multiplication and division so i'm going
to go ahead and copy this code and i'm
just going to paste it down here and
down here instead of checking minus
we're just going to check division and
then if it is division we're going to
divide the numbers and then finally i'm
going to check for multiplication so i'm
going to say
asterisk for multiplication and then
num1 times
num2
so we're able to cover all four
operations right addition subtraction
division and multiplication
each time um whatever the user enters
we're going to perform the correct
operation right this if statement's
pretty simple
but let's say that the user enters in an
operator that's not equal to
any of these guys up here right what if
they enter in like a random character
like a string of text well we want to be
able to throw an error message so what i
can do is i can come down here and just
say else
and then inside of this else block i'm
just going to say
console.writeline and i'm just going to
print out like
invalid
operator so this will basically tell
them like hey you hadn't you had an
invalid operator like that's not good
so now we have our whole program and we
used our little if else structure here
to
figure out what was stored inside of
that op
variable so we figured out what the user
wanted us to do let's go ahead and run
this program and we'll see how we did
over here it says enter a number i'm
going to enter 10
and enter an operator why don't we do
addition and enter another number why
don't we do like 5.5
so now when i hit enter that if
statement is going to execute and it's
going to see that plus sign and it's
going to be able to add the numbers so
you see here we get 15.5 so we
successfully added the numbers together
let's try a different one i want to do
multiplication so let's do 60
times
4.23
and we get 253 yeah that seems about
right all right so let's try one more
and we'll try to break it so i'm
basically just going to enter a number
40 and now i'm going to enter in an
invalid operator so i'm going to enter
in like an h for the operator and then
we'll enter in a five
and now this should tell us invalid
operator because
the program didn't recognize that
operator in other words it wasn't able
to handle that so we threw our little
error message and that's essentially all
we need to do to build this four
function calculator the magic is in the
if statement so we can use the if
statement to figure out what calculation
or what operation the user wanted to do
and we can just keep using all these
different elsif's in order to figure
that out so this is extremely useful and
hopefully you can find a use for
something like this in your programs
in this tutorial i want to show you guys
how to use switch statements in c sharp
now a switch statement is basically just
a special type of if statement where we
can check a bunch of different
conditions really easily and this will
all be really clear in the example that
i show you guys so let's go ahead and
get started
down here in my program i just have a
very simple program set up and in this
tutorial i want to create a method so
we're actually going to create a method
which is going to convert numbers into
days of the week so if i pass this
method to zero it would give me back
sunday because sunday is the first day
of the week if i pass this a one it
would give me back a
monday right if i pass this a two
it would give me back
tuesday etc right so if i you know it's
basically gonna map numbers to the
specific day of the week that we're
gonna give it and this is gonna be a
pretty cool uh method so i'm going to
come down here and we're going to go
ahead and write the method i'm just
going to say static and this is going to
return a string so it's going to return
the name of the day of the week
and i'm just going to call this
get day
and this method is going to take one
parameter and it's going to be the
day num so i'm just going to call this
day num so day num is going to be like 0
1 2 3 4 5 6 etc right it's going to be a
number
and we're going to take that number and
we're going to convert it into a day of
the week right we're going to convert it
into a string which would be the day of
the week
so i'm going to create a variable over
here it's going to be a string variable
and i'm just going to call it day name
and i'm not going to give it a value and
then down here eventually our goal is
going to be
going to be to return day name
so inside of our little method over here
inside of our um method block our goal
is to populate this day name variable
with the value right with the correct
value that's going to correspond to the
day num that gets passed in cool so i'm
going to show you guys how we can use a
special structure in c sharp to do this
and it's called a switch statement so
i'm going to set up my switch statement
i'm just going to say
switch i'm going to make an open and
close parenthesis and open and close
curly bracket
and down here we're going to be able to
start writing our switch statement now
the switch david needs one piece of
information inside of this parentheses
and it basically needs a value so the
whole point of the switch statement is
we're going to pass it a value and then
we're going to check to see if that
value is equal to a bunch of different
stuff and depending on what it's equal
to we're going to do different things so
this will be clear in a second in here
i'm going to pass in day numb because if
daenum is zero i want to do something if
daenum is one i want to do something
else if daenum is two i want to do
something else in other words my goal is
to figure out what the day numb is and
depending on what it is i'm going to do
something in other words i'm going to
give this day name variable a different
value now down here in the switch
statement we can make what are called
cases so i can come down here and i can
just type out case
and over here i can just type in a value
so i could say zero here
and i'm gonna make a colon down here i'm
basically just gonna say day name is
equal to
sunday and i'm also going to say
break down here so let's talk about what
this is saying essentially this line
this little block of code is saying that
in the case
that day num is equal to 0 i want to do
this
so in the case that day num has the
value of 0 we're going to do whatever i
specify down here essentially what i'm
doing is i'm saying day name is going to
be equal to sunday and i'm also saying
break and we're going to talk about
break in one second so now what i can do
is i can create one of these cases for
each of the possible numbers right
so now instead of just making one for
zero i'll make one for one in the case
that day num is one i'm going to say day
name is going to be equal to monday
right and then again i'm going to say
break and we'll do this one more time
i'm going to do it for
2.
so in the case that day num
is equal to 2
now i'm going to say day name is equal
to
tuesday
and you'll notice here i'm using this
break statement and this is a special
reserved word in c sharp which basically
says that we want to break out of the
structure that we're currently in so
we're inside of this switch statement
and essentially what happens is with
this switch statement it's going to look
through all of these different cases so
it's going to say okay is it 0 is it 1
is it 2. but let's say that day num is
zero right so it says is case zero yes
we're gonna execute this we're gonna
assign a value of sunday to day num
if i don't put this break statement in
here then c is going to keep checking
all of these cases after that so it's
not going to stop it's going to keep
checking so if you have a scenario where
you want to be able to keep checking the
other cases even after one of them was
true then you can get rid of the break
statement but i think in most cases
you'll probably just want this break
statement in there all right so i've
made one of these for sunday monday and
tuesday i'm going to go off and make
some for the rest of the days of the
week and then we'll come back and check
it out all right so i went ahead and
made one of these for every day of the
week you can see we have sunday monday
tuesday wednesday thursday friday and
saturday and this is a really easy way
to check all these different cases right
i can just say k6 day name saturday etc
so we basically have our case statement
set up we have our switch statement
set up but here's the problem let's say
that the user passes a value into this
method that's not zero through six
right so this case this switch statement
can only handle values 0 through 6 but
what happens if someone passed like a
100 into there well i can actually
account for that so down here i can
create something called a default i can
basically just type out default i can
type a colon and now down here i can
specify what i want to do if none of
these cases are true so i could come
down here and i could basically just say
day name and we'll just set this equal
to
invalid number or why don't we say
invalid day number and this will
basically act as like a error message
and then down here we're also going to
need to say break so
this is essentially how we can account
for any values that aren't included up
here as cases
so
our function or our method seems to be
done at this point so let's go ahead and
try it out so remember get day is going
to take one value which is going to be a
numb and let's go up here to our main
method and we'll try this out so i'm
actually just going to print out
whatever we get so i'm going to say
console.writeline
and i'm going to go ahead and print out
getday and let's pass this a0 so i'm
going to go ahead and say getday0 so
hopefully we should get sunday back
because
sunday is mapped to zero
and you'll see over here that we get
sunday back so let's try another one why
don't we try
four
and i think four is gonna be thursday
yeah so thursday
and let's try one more so i'm gonna try
an invalid number so let's put 80 in
here so if i say get day 80 now we
should get that error message which
tells us that it's an invalid day number
yeah so over here we're getting that
invalid day number so that's basically
what we can do as switch statements now
let me just point this out everything
that you can do with switch statements
you could actually do with if statements
the reason that we have switch
statements though is because they make
it a lot easier to do essentially what
we're doing over here you could do it
with if statements but it would be a lot
messier than this and it would be a lot
harder to manage with switch statements
it's very clear right it's very clear
what's going on and what values are
getting mapped to what code so switch
statements are extremely useful and you
should definitely consider using them in
your c sharp programs
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how to use while loops in c-sharp
now while loop is basically a
programming structure that allows us to
loop over a specific block of code while
a certain condition is true
basically using while loops we're able
to keep doing something repeatedly while
a condition is true and this can come in
handy in a bunch of situations and loops
are extremely useful in a programming
language like c-sharp so let's get
started i'm going to show you guys how
they work and how to use them basically
just to give you a general introduction
into while loops
down here in my main method i'm actually
going to create one thing and this isn't
going to be the wow loop i'm just going
to create a variable it's going to be an
int and i'm just going to call it index
and i'm going to set it equal to one and
we're going to end up using this index
variable inside of our loop so now i
want to create a while loop so i'm just
going to say
wow and i'm going to make an open and
close parentheses and an open and close
curly bracket now here's how while loops
work up here in these parentheses i'm
going to specify a condition so if
you're familiar with if statements
you'll know that with an if statement we
have a condition right we check a
condition and if that condition is true
then we execute the code inside of the
if statement pretty simple
it's the same concept with this while
loop up here in this while loop i'm
going to specify a condition and if this
condition's true i'm going to be able to
execute all of the code that goes down
here in these curly brackets the only
thing is with a while loop not only are
we gonna execute at one time but we're
gonna keep continuously executing it
until the condition up here in these
parentheses is false so we're basically
gonna check this condition if it's true
we'll execute all the code inside of
these curly brackets and then we'll come
up we'll check the condition again if
it's still true we'll come down and
execute it again so you're continuously
looping through this code so it's
essentially an if statement but you keep
going until the condition is false and
over here in these parenthesis we need
to specify our condition so i'm going to
make a condition i'm just going to say
wow
index is less than or equal to
5.
so as long as this index variable is
less than or equal to 5 i'm going to
keep executing all the code down here
and then down here i'm basically just
going to write a few lines of code so
i'm going to say console
dot right line and we're going to print
out the value of index
and then down here i'm going to
increment the value of index so i'm
going to say index plus plus and
remember this plus plus basically just
adds one onto the index so essentially
what's happening is every time we go
through this loop i'm going to print out
the value of index
then i'm going to increment index and
then i'm going to go up back here and
check the condition again so this is our
basic while loop i'm going to run the
while loop we'll see what happens and
then i'm going to explain exactly what
happens so we can get a better idea of
how this works
let's go ahead and run the program
and you'll see over here i'm printing
out one through five and maybe you
expected that maybe you didn't but this
is what we got and i'm going to go ahead
and explain exactly how this happened
step by step so the first thing we did
up here was we created this integer
index and we set it equal to one right
now then we created our while loop so
when c sharp goes to execute our program
it's first gonna create this variable
index and it's gonna store one inside of
there then the next thing it's gonna do
is check this condition so the first
thing before it executes any of the code
inside the loop before it does anything
else it's going to check this condition
so it's going to check to see if index
is less than or equal to 5. since index
was equal to 1 initially that's going to
be true
so then c sharp is going to go down it's
going to execute this line so it's going
to print out index onto the console as
you can see over here then it's going to
increment index so index is now going to
be equal to 2.
then c sharp is going to go all the way
back up to this condition and check it
again so before c sharp is going to
execute that code a second time it needs
to check the condition again so now
index is equal to two and two is less
than or equal to five so c sharp's gonna
come down here it's gonna print out two
as you can see right there and it's
gonna increment index then it goes all
the way back up and checks the condition
again right so every single time we
execute all that code before it's going
to execute it again it goes back up and
checks the condition
all right eventually we're going to get
to a point where index is going to be
equal to 5 and we printed out five over
here
then we're going to increment it to six
c sharp is going to come up here and
it's gonna check is six less than or
equal to five and then the condition is
going to be false so we're gonna break
out of the while loop just like that and
that's essentially how we can use these
while loops so it's very simple right
you specify a condition and you're going
to keep looping through the loop as long
as that condition is true easy enough
now i do want to warn you guys of
something there is a possibility of
something called an infinite loop and an
infinite loop is a situation where this
condition up here never becomes false so
for example if i was to get rid of this
index plus plus
now this condition up here index less
than or equal to five this is always
going to be true right because we're
never modifying the value of index when
we were incrementing it eventually we
would increment it enough to get to five
but since we're not incrementing it
anymore we're just gonna loop infinitely
so let me show you guys what happens
when i do this when i run my program
you'll see over here that i'm just
constantly printing out one i mean this
it's literally just printing out one as
fast as it can and it's gonna do this
forever if i let it it'll do this
infinitely because
it's never told that it needs to stop in
other words this condition up here is
never
false and so that's why we have an
infinite loop and that's probably gonna
happen to you as you play around with
loops everyone's had an infinite loop
before
and in most cases you're going to want
to avoid them although there are some
special cases where you're actually
going to want infinite loops
so that's sort of the basics of while
loops it's very simple right we have a
condition up here as long as that
condition's true we're going to keep
executing the code down here and every
single time we go through the loop we
check that condition again
i want to show you guys uh one more
thing and there's actually another type
of loop that we can use which is similar
to a while loop it's called a do while
loop and in order for me to kind of
illustrate what this is doing i want to
show you guys an example so if i came up
here and set index equal to six
let's talk about what's going to happen
so if index is equal to six right the
first thing that my program does with
this while loop is it checks this
condition so the first thing before it
executes any of this code before it's
allowed to even touch that code
it checks this condition so since index
is equal to 6 and this condition is
getting checked before we execute the
code
this code is never going to execute
because 6 is not less than or equal to
5. this condition is false so we're
never going to execute this code so if i
run my program you guys will see that
nothing gets printed out right we don't
execute any of the code inside that
while loop but there's actually another
type of loop which is essentially the
opposite of a while loop and i'm going
to show you guys that so i'm basically
going to take this while loop
declaration up here i'm going to throw
it down here and i want to make sure i
put a semicolon after it
and then up here instead of saying while
i'm going to say do
and so now we have another type of loop
which is a do while loop and the
difference between a do while loop and a
while loop is that a do while loop will
execute the code inside of the loop
before it checks the condition so now
even though index is equal to six we're
still going to be able to execute this
loop one time before we look at the
condition right so it's basically going
to execute all this code then it's going
to look at the condition it's going to
figure out that it's false and it's
going to go ahead and break out of this
so i'm going to show you guys how we can
do this and i'm just going to run my
program and you'll see that even though
this condition was false even though 6
is not less than or equal to 5 we were
still able to print it out one time
because in a do while loop you execute
the code inside the loop first and then
you check the condition so
that's basically another type of loop
that we can use
and do while loops definitely come in
handy and there's a lot of situations
where you want to use them although i
would say that by a huge majority while
loops are
more useful but do while loops are also
awesome so that's kind of the basics of
while loops and do while loops and this
is really just the basics of looping in
general there's a lot of situations when
we're programming where we're going to
want to continually do the same thing
until a certain condition is false and
that kind of gives you an overview of
how it works
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how to build a guessing game in c
sharp now this is going to be a very
basic guessing game essentially we're
going to define a secret word
and then the user is going to have to
try and guess that word and we're going
to keep asking the user to try and guess
it until they get it right so this is
going to be kind of cool and i'm gonna
show you guys how we can use uh some of
the stuff that we've learned in this
course so far things like loops and uh
if statements and variables we're gonna
use all of them together to create this
cool game
so let's start creating the game um
remember this is gonna be a guessing
game so the first thing we want to do is
come up with a word that the user is
going to have to guess so i'm going to
create a variable and it's just going to
be a string and i'm just going to call
it secret word
and the secret word why don't we just
give it a value we'll set it equal to
draft so draft is going to be the secret
word and the user's goal for our game is
going to be to try and guess that secret
word now i want to create one more
variable and we're actually going to
call this one
guess so this is going to be another
string and i'm just going to say it's
called guess and why don't we just set
it equal to this empty string over here
so i'm not really
giving this a value yet
all right so now we have our secret word
and we also have our guess and what i
want to do is i want to be able to keep
prompting the user to guess the word
until they get it correctly so anytime
in c-sharp that we want to keep doing
something repeatedly until a certain
condition is false we're going to use a
while loop so i'm going to go ahead and
create a while loop
and i'm just going to make an open and
close parentheses open and close curly
bracket
and there's really two things to this
while loop the first thing is going to
be a condition and the second thing is
going to be the code that we want to
continually execute so let's think this
through
what condition do we want to put up here
well basically we want to keep looping
while the guess
is not equal to
the secret word in other words as long
as the guess that the user guesses isn't
equal to what the secret word is we want
to keep looping and keep asking them to
guess so down here what i want to do is
keep prompting them to guess so i'm
basically just going to say
console.write
and i'll write out to the screen a
prompt i'll say enter guess
and then now that we've prompted them to
enter the guess what i want to do is i
want to take whatever they entered store
it inside of this guess variable and
that way we can keep checking it every
time we go through this loop so down
here i'm basically just going to say
guess
is equal to
console.readline so i'm going to go
ahead and read the line of text that the
user enters basically just read whatever
word they entered in and store it inside
of this guess variable so essentially
what's happening now is every time we go
through the loop we're prompting the
user to guess the word and we're storing
whatever they guess inside of this guest
variable then we're going to go up here
and we're going to check to see if it's
equal to the secret word if it's not
equal to the secret word then we're
going to go through and ask them again
but if it is equal to the secret word
then we're going to go ahead and break
out of the loop and then down here we
can just print out a success message so
i can just print out console.write and
i'll just print out you win so
this is our program it's actually a
pretty um easy program and i do just
want to point out that in addition to
using a while loop we also could have
used a do while loop in order to write
this program so if you want a little
challenge and you want to try and
challenge yourself go ahead and try to
write this with a do while loop instead
of a while loop and if you need to
figure out what do while loops are just
check out the previous tutorial i
explained what they were but for our
case i'm just doing it with a simple
while loop just to keep it as
straightforward as possible but like i
said if you want a challenge try it with
a do while loop so let's see if we can
run our program believe it or not this
is actually all the code that we need
for this guessing game so i'm going to
go ahead and run the program
now you'll see over here it says enter
guess so i'm just going to type in some
random text
and you'll notice that because this text
didn't match the secret word draft
it's asking me to enter again
so
i'm going to keep entering and i could
keep entering essentially infinitely
many times and it's going to keep
prompting me to guess until i get the
word but if i was to type in the secret
word so if i was to type in draft here
now when i hit enter
draft is equal to the secret word so
we're going to break out of that while
loop and we're going to get this you win
message so that's essentially all our
game did it it allowed us to keep
guessing the word until we got it right
so this is a pretty cool game and you
know you guys can see down here it's
actually pretty easy for us to implement
it was only you know maybe like seven or
eight lines of code
but i think there's a little problem
with this game and the problem is that
the user gets unlimited guesses right so
the user can just keep guessing
infinitely i mean technically they
technically they could type in you know
every possible combination of letters
until they got the secret word right and
that's not a very good game i think what
would make this game better would be
imposing a guess limit so we could say
like the user can only guess three times
or they can only guess four times and if
they don't get it in four guesses then
they lose the game i think that would be
a little bit better game so why don't we
try to implement that let's see if we
can come up with some code that will
allow us to program that game well i
think i know what we need to do so the
first thing we want to do is we need
some way to keep track of how many times
the user guesses right if we're going to
impose a guess limit on this game we
need to be able to keep track of how
many times they've guessed
so that was a good place to start why
don't we just start with that i'm going
to create an integer and i'm just going
to call it guest count and we'll set it
equal to zero initially right because
initially the user hasn't guessed at all
and what we want to do is we want to
increment this variable every time the
user guesses so let's go down here and
you'll notice this is the code down here
that allows the user to guess right it's
this code which is essentially prompting
the user to guess and then storing their
guess so in addition to prompting them
and storing the guess we can also
increment the guest count so i can come
down here and i can say
guest count plus plus right just like
that so i'm incrementing the guest count
every single time they guess awesome but
we're still going to need some more
information so another piece of
information we're going to need is the
guess limit so we need to essentially
tell our program how many times the user
can guess
so i'm just going to make another in and
i'll just call this guess limit and over
here we can define how many times we
want the user to be able to guess
well why don't we say three guesses i
think three guesses is enough
three strikes in your out and so now
we're basically limiting the user to
three guesses i also want to create one
more variable and this is going to be a
boolean
and this is going to be called
out of guesses and i'm going to set this
equal to false and this boolean is
basically going to tell us whether or
not the user is out of guesses so if the
user still has guesses left this is
going to be equal to false but if the
user is out of guesses then this is
going to be equal to true so we're going
to set it to false initially
and then down here we need to use these
two new variables
inside of this while loop so
the first thing i think we should do is
we should only allow the user to guess
when they still have guesses left right
in other words i only want the user to
be able to guess the word if they
haven't already guessed three times
right if they haven't guessed the guess
limit so what we can do is we can
actually create an if statement so i can
say if
and down here i'm going to make open and
close curly brackets and inside of these
parentheses i need to put a condition so
let's think about this what do we want
to check well i want to check to see if
the user is out of guesses right so i
can check to see if
the guess count is less than
the guess limit and if this is true in
other words if the guest count is less
than the guest limit then the user still
has a guest left so they can go ahead
and guess so i'm going to take all this
code for guessing and i'm going to put
it inside of these curly brackets right
so once again
we're checking this condition if the
guest count is less than the guest limit
then we're gonna go ahead and print out
all of this stuff so we're gonna allow
them to guess the word and then we'll
increment the guest count but if this
isn't the case in other words if guest
count isn't less than the guest limit
that means that they've already reached
their guest limit right that means they
don't have any guesses left so i can say
else down here
and if they run out of guesses
what i want to do is i want to modify
this out of guesses variable so when
they run out of guesses in other words
when this condition is false i want to
say out of guesses is equal to true so
i'm going to say out of
guesses is equal to true so basically
what we're doing down here is we're
saying hey they're out of guesses and
this is actually what we would call like
a flag so you'll hear people sometimes
call these like boolean flags
this is basically just a value that's
giving us a piece of information right
this is telling us that the user's out
of guesses so there's one more thing we
have to do in this while loop you'll
notice that this while loop is going to
keep executing as long as the guess is
not equal to the secret word but now
since we're adding in the guess limit
there's actually another situation where
we're going to want to stop looping and
that situation is when the user is out
of guesses so i want to modify this i
want to say that we want to keep
guessing wow they haven't guessed the
secret word
and they're not
out of guesses right because if they
haven't guessed the secret word then we
want to keep asking them but
if they ran out of guesses then we want
to break out of the loop right so i'm
going to keep looping while the guess is
not equal to the secret word and the
user is not out of guesses so now we
have a while loop set up which is going
to allow us to specify a guess limit
so there's one more thing we have to do
which is down here now down here we're
basically just saying you win right so
whenever we break out of the loop we're
telling them that they won here's the
problem though so there's two situations
now where they could break out of the
loop when the guess is equal to the
secret word in other words when they
guess correctly
but there's also another situation which
is when they're run out of guesses right
and so down here we're not going to be
super sure which situation occurred so
what we can do is we can use another if
statement and we can check so i can
basically say if
and i can check to see if they're out of
guesses so i can say if out of guesses
if this is true
then i want to print out a lose message
so i'm basically just going to say you
lose
but otherwise if it's not true
that means that they guess the word
correctly so we can go ahead and
put this win message down here
all right so that is essentially
everything we need to do to specify the
guest limit i know this is a lot of code
why don't we run our program we'll play
the game make sure we got everything
right and then we can come back and we
can kind of go over what we did again so
i'm gonna run the program
it says enter guess so i'm gonna go
ahead and lose the game so remember we
have three guesses so i can just type in
some random guess another one now we're
on our third and final guess if i don't
get the word this time we're gonna lose
so i'm not gonna get it
and i'm gonna click enter and it says
you lose so it was able to figure out
that we didn't guess the secret word in
three tries and it told us that we lost
the game cool
so now let's see if we can win the game
so i'm gonna go ahead and run this
program and it's gonna say enter guests
so let's enter two wrong guesses now
we're on our last try
let's say i have a stroke of genius and
i type in the right word
and it says you win so the program is
now smart enough to
um
play this game with a guess limit let's
go over one more time what we did we
created a bunch of variables up here the
secret word is pretty obvious the guess
is just storing what they guessed the
guest count is keeping track of how many
times the users guessed right so every
time we run the code to
allow them to guess the word we're going
to increment it the guess limit is just
telling us how many times they can guess
and this out of guesses variable is
basically going to tell us whether or
not the user has run out of guesses so
down here we have our loop and this loop
is basically just going to keep going
and keep asking the user to guess the
word and it's going to keep doing that
as long as the guess is not equal to the
secret word and as long as the user is
not out of guesses so if either of those
conditions is false we're going to break
out of the loop the first thing we do in
the loop is we basically use this if
statement and we say if guess count is
less than guess limit and so if the
guest count is less than the guess limit
in other words if they haven't um
guessed three times in our case then
we're going to prompt them for another
guess but if they have guessed three
times
then we're going to set this out of
guess's variable equal to true and
that's going to trigger
us breaking out of the loop so if we do
break out of the loop there's two
situations right the first situation is
that we won the game and we guessed the
secret word correctly but the other is
that we ran out of guesses so down here
i'm basically checking that i'm checking
if we're out of guesses if we are that
means we lost otherwise that means we
won
and so that's the basics of building
this program and i do just want to say
um
this while loop up here we used a simple
while loop to do this but you could also
run this program using a do while loop
and so if you want a challenge if you
really understand what's going on here
and you you know you're pretty solid on
what's going on a good challenge would
be to try and build this program with a
do while loop instead of a while loop um
it's gonna be pretty similar a lot of
the code can stay the same but there are
gonna be some key differences that
you're gonna have to try to account for
so if you're looking for a challenge
try to build this with a do while loop
but otherwise that's sort of how you
build the guessing game and you know in
this tutorial we were able to integrate
a lot of the stuff that we've learned up
to this point in the course like
variables we used all different types of
variables we used the loops we also used
if statements so hopefully this gives
you an idea of how you could build
something like this using all that stuff
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how to use a for loop in c sharp a
for loop is a special type of loop which
allows us to keep track of what's called
an iterating variable and basically this
is just a variable that's going to
change every time we go through our loop
so basically it's kind of a situation
where we have a variable and generally
that variable will like keep track of
how many times we've gone through the
loop or it can keep track of other
things but it's sort of a special
scenario in our programs where we want
to use a loop but we want to have a
variable that's going to be changing or
doing something every time we go through
that loop and this is actually really
easy to understand i'm just going to
show you guys real quick this example
that i have down here you'll notice that
i have a simple while loop so i said
this integer i over here i set it equal
to 1
and i'm looping while i is less than or
equal to five right this is a very
simple while loop and every time we go
through the loop i'm basically saying
console.writeline i'm printing out i
and then i basically saying i plus plus
so a very simple loop
and but you'll notice here when i run my
program and i'm going to go ahead and
run it right now
that i'm basically printing out this
variable i every time i go through the
loop and you'll notice that the first
time we go through the loop i is equal
to one the second time we go through the
loop i is equal to two the third time we
go through the loop i is equal to three
this variable i is constantly changing
every time we go through the loop and i
is actually telling us what iteration of
the loop we're currently on
this is pretty cool right this variable
i is essentially keeping track of the
times we've gone through the loop and we
can use this variable i to you know
print that out and to know where we're
at in the execution of the while loop
this is actually a very common situation
so a lot of times when we're writing
loops in c sharp we're going to want to
have a variable just like i a variable
that's going to change every time we go
through the loop right in this case i is
changing every time it's getting
incremented by one so i is essentially
telling us how many times we've gone
through the loop but you could
essentially use this variable i to do
anything so instead of just incrementing
i by one i could drink i could increment
it by two or i can increment it by
another value
basically the idea here is that we have
a variable that we're using constantly
as we go through this loop and it's such
a common situation to have a variable
like this that there's an entirely
separate loop called a for loop which is
designed just for this situation so down
here i'm going to go ahead and create a
for loop and i'll show you guys how this
for loop is actually going to be able to
do exactly what this while loop is doing
but a lot cleaner and a lot simpler to
create a four loop i'm just going to say
four i'm going to make an open and close
parentheses and an open and close curly
bracket so so far this is exactly like
this while loop right it's basically
structured the same exact way but you'll
notice in the while loop inside of the
parentheses i only put one thing right i
put the loop condition you'll hear
people call this the loop guard right
it's basically like the condition for
when we should loop inside of this for
loops parentheses we're going to put
three different things so instead of
just having one thing we're going to put
three things the first thing we're going
to put in here is a variable
initialization you'll notice up here in
my while looping structure i have this
integer i and over here i'm saying in i
is equal to one but this is actually
outside of the while loop so i had to do
that separately from the actual while
loop well in a for loop i can actually
do this same thing inside of this
parentheses so i'm going to copy this
and i'm going to paste it over here and
you'll notice i'm going to leave this
semicolon in so the first thing i'm
going to do inside this for loop
parentheses is i'm going to initialize
this variable i
now the next thing i want to do and
you'll notice i'm separating these two
things with a semicolon the next thing i
want to do is write out my loop
condition so in the while loop our loop
condition is right here you know what i
mean it's just i is less than or equal
to five whatever it's basically like
telling us how long we should loop for i
can just take this and i can put this as
the second item inside of these
parentheses so now i'm able to take the
variable initialization and the loop
condition and finally i'm going to put
another semicolon here and i'm going to
include one more thing over here and
this is going to be a line of code
that's going to get executed every time
we go through the for loop now if you'll
notice up here in this while loop every
time we go through this loop we're doing
something special to this variable
every time we go through the while loop
we're incrementing i and this is exactly
what i want to do over here in my
parentheses so the last spot inside of
my parentheses over here i'm just going
to put in i plus plus and like i said
this is just going to be a line of code
that's going to get executed after every
single iteration
of our loop so you'll basically see that
i'm doing the same thing over here as i
am over here right over here i'm
defining this variable i'm initializing
this variable with a value i'm doing
that down here in the parentheses over
here i'm specifying a looping condition
i'm doing that down here in the
parentheses and then finally down here
after every iteration of the loop i'm
incrementing i and i'm able to do that
over here in this third section so
basically the for loop is just taking
this situation where we want to have a
variable that's going to you know be
used inside the loop and it's compacting
it into this one single structure so now
i could basically copy this line of code
over here paste it into the for loop and
now these loops are identical so these
loops are actually going to be doing the
same exact
thing and i'm going to prove that to you
guys so i'm going to go ahead and get
rid of this while loop
and we only have the for loop now and
let's run our program and see what
output we get so i'm going to run the
program and you'll see we're getting the
same exact output that we got before
we're getting one two three four five
printed out so this for loop is doing
exactly what that while loop is doing
it's just it's a lot more compact it's a
lot easier to manage and it's a lot
better for us so let me walk you guys
real quick through how this gets
executed essentially what happens is the
first thing we do is we create this
variable and we give it an initial value
the second thing we do is we check this
condition if the condition is true then
we're going to execute all of the code
inside of here once we're done executing
all that code then we're going to go up
here and increment i
then we're going to check the condition
again if it's true we'll come back down
here and we'll execute this code then
again we're coming back up here and
we're going to do that and then we check
the condition again so it's continuously
looping through just like that and this
is the same as that while loop so you
could do what we're doing here with a
while loop it's just that it's a lot
more convenient and a lot easier to do
it with a for loop so that's kind of the
basics of a for loop and before i end
this tutorial i want to show you guys
one cool thing we can do with these
up here i have this um array that i
created and i just kind of commented it
out but i'm going to copy it and bring
it down here
and you'll notice this is just an array
of lucky numbers so it's just an integer
array and i have these numbers in here
there's like four different numbers i'm
going to show you guys how we can use a
for loop in order to loop through and
print out all of the elements inside of
this array so i just want to remind you
the way that we can access an individual
element in an array is by saying the
array's name and then referring to the
index of that
value so if i said lucky number zero
this is referring to this four if i said
lucky numbers two this is referring to
this 15 right basically that's how we
can access an element inside of an array
for loops are really useful remember we
have this indexing variable so i can use
a for loop to actually loop through and
print out all the elements inside of an
array so down here so i actually want to
modify a couple of values i'm going to
say int i
instead of setting it equal to 1 i'm
going to set it equal to 0 because
array indexes start at 0. so this
element is element 0 inside of the array
then i'm going to change this condition
so instead of saying i less than or
equal to 5 i want to say i less than or
equal to
lucky numbers dot
length so this is going to allow me to
access the length of the array so when i
say luckynumbers.length
this is going to tell me how many
elements are inside of the array
then down here i'm going to say
console.writeline and i want to print
out
lucky numbers
i
and the way this is going to work is the
first time we go through this loop we're
going to be printing out
lucky number zero right because i is
initially going to be zero so the first
time we go through here we're basically
printing out lucky number zero the
second time we go through i gets
incremented so we're going to be
printing out lucky numbers one
the third time we're going to be
printing out lucky numbers two etc so we
can use this for loop in order to loop
through this array and let me show you
guys when i run this program and
actually you know i forgot to modify one
more thing so instead of saying less
than or equal to here i'm just going to
say less than and basically since we're
starting at zero i want to say i is less
than lucky numbers dot length that's
because the length of the array is gonna
be one two three four five six
but the last element in the array is at
index position five so if i say i is
less than or equal to lucky
numbers.length then we're gonna be
trying to access lucky numbers six at
one point but
the last element is at lucky numbers
five so we have to say less than so i'm
going to change this back to an i and
let's go ahead and run this and you'll
see that we'll be printing out all the
elements inside of that array so we're
printing out 4 8 15 16 23 42. so that's
one very common use of these for loops
is you can use them to
loop through all the elements inside of
an array
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how to build an exponent function
in c sharp so an exponent function is
basically a function where we can pass
in two numbers a base number and a power
number and it'll take the base number to
the power number so essentially it's
gonna like if i passed in a two and a
three
it would give me two raised to the third
power right or if i passed in a four and
a seven it would give me 4 raised to the
7th power that's essentially what we
want to
write in this tutorial so i'm going to
come down here below my main method and
i'm actually going to create this
function so i'm just going to say static
and we're actually going to return a
integer so why don't we just have this
accept integers we'll just keep it
simple
and i'm just going to call this um
get pow so this will basically like get
the power
and
i'm going to make some open and closed
curly brackets and in here we're going
to accept two parameters so the first is
going to be an integer base num and the
second is going to be an integer um pow
num
so we'll basically take the base numb
and raise it to
the pound um right so if base numbers
two and pound numbers three then we'll
do two cubed right kind of makes sense
so this is going to be a cool little
method and it kind of poses an
interesting challenge because
we don't know what base num and pow num
is
right if we knew what power number was
for example if we knew power number was
two then i could just say
base num times
base knob right i could just square base
number we'd be good to go but i don't
know what poundnum is so i don't know
how many times i need to multiply base
num by itself
in order to get the answer so this kind
of poses an interesting challenge and
i'm going to show you guys how we can
use a for loop to solve this challenge
so the first thing i want to do is just
create an integer and i'm just going to
call this result
and i'm just going to set result equal
to one and then eventually what we want
to do is return result
so we want to modify result enough where
it represents base num taken to pow num
okay
and what we need to do is we need to
keep multiplying result times base num
pound times so let me show you guys we
can create a for loop and i'm just going
to create a simple for loop
and remember
when we're creating for loops the first
thing we want to do is create a
variable so i'm just going to say int i
is equal to
zero and i'm going to start this off at
zero
and then what i want to do is create a
looping guard so a condition in other
words we're saying we want to keep
looping as long as this condition is
true so i want to keep looping as long
as i is less than pound num and when i
say this this is basically telling c
sharp that i want to keep looping
poundum times so if poundum is equal to
three we're going to execute this loop
three times if poundnum is equal to five
we'll execute it five times etcetera and
the last thing we want to put inside of
this for loop is going to be something
we want to do after each iteration of
the loop so i'm just going to increment
i
and this is a very very very simple for
loop um so we're looping through here
poundnum times so like i said if pound
number is two we'll go here through here
two times and every time i go through
this loop i basically just wanna
multiply
result
times base number so i can say result is
equal to result
times base numb just like that
so the first time we go through this
loop result is going to be equal to one
right so the first time we go through
result is going to be equal to one so
now result will be equal to one times
base num right the first time through
results gonna essentially um become
equal to base num the second time we go
through results equal to base num right
so we're essentially multiplying base
num by base num in other words base num
squared and storing it inside of this
result variable and we're going to keep
doing that through each iteration so if
we go through this loop three times then
result is going to have the value of
base num cubed if we go through this
loop five times result will have the
value of base num taken to the power of
five right and then down here we can
just return result so by using this for
loop we're actually able to figure out
what the answer is so up here inside my
main method let's go ahead and run this
and i'm actually going to print out the
answer so i'll just say
console.writeline
and we're going to write the result of
getpow so why don't we try to do like 3
squared right so we'll pass in 3 and 2
and i'm going to go ahead and run this
program so we should get the result of 3
squared which is going to be 9.
and you can see over here we get 9. now
i just want to point out this um this
get pow method is only going to work for
positive number
um powers so we're not going to be able
to do like 3 and negative 2. that's not
going to work down here
but we can do positive number um
exponents so i could say like three two
why don't we try like four and three so
this is going to be four cubed so we
should get 64
and yeah we get 64. all right so looks
like this method's working so once again
i'll just walk you through what we did
this get pow method accepted two
parameters base num and pow num so the
goal was to take base num to pound them
we created this for loop over here and
essentially all i did was i set i equal
to zero and we're going to keep looping
as long as i is less than poundnum and
what that means is we're going to go
through this loop poundnum times so if
poundum was five that means we went
through this for loop five times and
every time we went through this for loop
we multiplied result which was initially
equal to one
we we said result is going to be equal
to result times base num so the first
time through the loop
result was equal to one so we ended up
getting result is equal to one times
base thumb so we got face numb second
time through the loop result was equal
to base num so we said result is equal
to base num times base number
essentially the third time through the
loop result was equal to base num
squared so essentially we were saying
result is equal to base num squared
times base number based on cubed and
that's essentially what we did and that
was actually enough for us to get base
num taken to pound on so
it's a pretty simple method although it
is a little bit complex because we use
this for loop so what you should do is
play around with this method and you
know write it on your own and see if you
can really wrap your head around what's
going on here
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how to use two-dimensional arrays
in c sharp a two-dimensional array is
basically a situation where we have an
array and every element inside of that
array is itself an array so essentially
we're building like a little matrix
structure inside of our program and i'm
going to show you guys how we can do
that it's actually pretty simple so if
we want to create a two-dimensional
array we can do it just like we would a
normal array so i'm going to create an
array of integers so we'll just say int
and now what i want to do is i want to
make an open and closed square bracket
and inside of this open and close square
bracket i'm just going to put a comma
here and basically this is telling c
sharp that we want to have a
two-dimensional array and i'm gonna give
this a name so i'm just gonna call this
number grid
and i'm gonna go ahead and set this
equal to something so now what we can do
is we can actually fill this array with
a bunch of different elements so i'm
gonna make an open and closed curly
bracket and then i'm going to make a new
line and down here we're actually going
to be able to populate this array with
elements so if i was making a normal
array i would usually just put in like a
bunch of numbers so i'd say like 1 2 3 4
etc
but when we're making a two-dimensional
array all of the elements inside of this
array need to be arrays so themselves
they have to be arrayed so the first
element has to be an array and the
second element would have to be an array
and the third element would have to be
an array etc
all of these elements have to be arrays
and then i could give these values so i
could say like 1
1 2 and then down here we could say like
3 4
and we could say five six so basically
now we have a little matrix of numbers
right not only does the number grid have
three elements but each of the elements
inside of the number grid has two
elements inside of it and this is a
two-dimensional array so let's look at
how we can actually access some of these
elements what i can do is i can come
down here and i'm just gonna say
console.writeline
and if i wanted to like for example
let's say i wanted to print out this
element over here i can just refer to
the name of the array so i can say
number grid and then i'm going to make
an open and close square bracket and in
here i'm going to put
two numbers so the first number i'm
going to put is going to be the element
inside of the array so it's going to be
like this is the first element this is
the second this is the third or this is
element at index position zero this is
element at index position one index
position two etc so i'm gonna put a zero
because we're trying to access this one
over here and then i'm gonna put another
zero so i'm just going to put 0 0 and
that's referring to row 0
column 0.
now when i run this program it's going
to be able to print that out so you'll
see we're printing out one we're
printing out that element over there
let's say that i wanted to access this 4
over here well this is going to be row 0
1 so i'm going to put a 1 right here
and then it's going to be 0 1 so it's
going to be 1 1.
and now when we print this out we should
get a four which we do so that's
essentially how you access those
elements inside the array and this works
exactly like um it does with a normal
array so if i wanted like i could modify
one of these values i can do everything
that i would do in a normal array and
that's kind of the basics this is a
structure that you might not use all the
time but when you need it it's extremely
useful and in addition to two dimensions
you could also have like three or four
or five dimensions all you have to do is
just put more like commas over here
there's also a situation where you might
not know how many elements you want to
go in there initially and you could
actually just like declare one of these
so i could say like int
and i'll make a two-dimensional array
and we'll just call this like
my array
and if i don't know what elements i want
to put in here initially i can actually
just say equals new int and then over
here i need to give this
some information so i would have to say
like two three and this is basically
telling
c sharp how many rows and how many
columns we want to have so this would
mean there's two elements and then each
of those elements has three elements
inside of it so that's another way that
you could do that and then you could
just manually like insert the elements
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how to use comments in c sharp now
comment is basically just a special line
or block of text in our program that's
going to get ignored when we run the
program so comments are really useful
for leaving little notes or comments
inside of your program and a comment is
essentially just a line of code that's
meant for humans and not meant for the
computer and these can come in handy so
i'm going to show you guys basically how
these work and what we can do with them
if i wanted to create a comment i could
just come down here and type two forward
slashes just like that and now you'll
see that the text in my text editor has
changed color
it's now this green color and that's
basically signifying that we have a
comment here so like i said a comment is
a little line or a little block of code
that's actually going to get ignored by
c sharp so when i run my program
anything that i have inside of this
comment is just going to get ignored the
comment is for the programmer so it's
for me or it's for another developer who
comes in and is reading my file so i
could leave like a little note here i
could say like a to do like you know
maybe this block of code needs to be
done
or i could even come in here and like
describe a line of code so i could
describe this line of code over here i
could say like this prints something out
etc
you could also take these comments and
put them after a line of code so i could
come over here and say two forward
slashes and you could type out you know
a comment whatever
and this is what we call a single line
comment so a single line comment is a
comment that can only be on one line so
if i was to make a new line you'll see
down here this is no longer a comment
and you'll see it's actually throwing an
error because the program is trying to
render it as actual code
but in addition to single line comments
like this a lot of times you're going to
want to have comments that are span
multiple lines one thing you can do is
just make multiple lines like that
and you'll see a lot of developers do
stuff like that you can also use a
starting and an ending tag so you can
type in a forward slash and a star
and now everything that comes after this
forward slash and a star in our file is
going to be considered a comment that is
until we end it off with another star
and a forward slash
so i can say star forward slash and now
you'll see only the stuff that's in
between these two little tags
is going to be considered a comment and
these can go on multiple lines so those
are basically the two types of comments
that we can use and really a comment is
extremely open-ended i mean there's no
wrong way to use a comment it's really
however you want to use it
and i do want to show you guys one other
way these can be useful so
let's say that i'm writing code and you
know i want to try and run my code
without a certain line in it so maybe
i'm like you know have a program and i
think one line might be causing it to
break where i just wanted to see what it
would look like without a single line of
code well one option would be to remove
that line of code so for example i can
take this line of code maybe this is a
line of code that i think is causing my
program problems i could delete it and
then i can go ahead and run the program
right and then nothing gets printed out
but here's the problem when i do that i
have to actually like physically remove
the line of code instead what i could do
is comment it out so i could just put a
comment in front of this and now this
whole thing is basically going to get
ignored by c sharp so i can run the
program and we're still going to be
running it without that line of code but
i don't have to physically delete it
from the file and that just allows me to
keep track of it a little bit better and
you know i can still have it there it's
still taking up space in the file it's
just going to get ignored so that can be
a really useful way so really i'd say
comments you know are basically used for
two things the first is like writing out
little messages or notes either for
yourself or for other programmers or for
commenting out lines of code and you'll
see people do both of those and they're
both uh really awesome so like i said
comments are pretty much open-ended you
can do whatever you want with them but
i'd say those are the two most common
use cases
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how to use exception handling in
c-sharp now a lot of times when your
c-sharp programs are running there's
going to be certain things that can go
wrong and generally when those
situations occur c sharp is going to
throw what's called an exception an
exception basically just tells you that
something happened in your code that
c-sharp couldn't handle and whenever an
exception gets thrown generally the
program crashes
so there's a lot of situations where
something might happen in the execution
of the program an exception is going to
get thrown and then the program's going
to terminate and sometimes you're going
to want that to happen sometimes when an
exception gets thrown you're going to
want the program to terminate because
you're going to want to know what
happened but a lot of times especially
if you're writing a program that's being
designed to run for you know months and
months at a time you're not going to
want an exception to crash the program
in other words you're going to want the
program to be able to keep going when
something wrong happens and an exception
gets thrown so i'm going to show you
guys the basics of working with
exceptions we're also going to talk
about handling exceptions and the
different scenarios where an exception
is going to get thrown down here i have
a basic program written out and this is
a very simple program essentially all it
does is it gets two numbers from the
user and it takes those numbers and it
divides them so you see over here i have
console.right i'm asking them to enter a
number and then i'm taking whatever they
entered and i'm converting it into an
integer and i'm storing it inside of
this integer variable and i'm doing that
for both of these numbers then down here
i'm just writing out the value of
dividing both numbers onto the screen so
there's two major things that we're
doing here the first is we're converting
this string into an integer using this
convert instruction and then down here
we're dividing the two numbers and i'm
going to show you guys how we could
actually enter in information to this
program that will cause exceptions so
let's go ahead and run this and i'm just
going to click start
so over here i'm going to enter a number
so why don't we enter in a five
and now i'm going to show you guys one
way that an exception could get thrown
so
remember we're dividing these two
numbers and you can't actually divide a
number by zero so just by basic math
rules if we have a whole number like
this
it's impossible for me to divide it by
zero so essentially what i'm doing here
is i'm asking the computer to do
something impossible right i'm asking
the computer to do something that it's
not going to be able to do and it's not
going to be able to handle
when i hit enter and i ask the computer
to do this it's going to throw an
exception in other words the computer is
going to be like hey i can't do this
like i can't divide these two numbers so
the program's gonna terminate so you'll
see when i hit enter
that this little screen goes away and
this exception pops up so it says
exception unhandled
system dot divide by zero exception
attempted to divide by zero it's
basically telling us what we're wrong
right saying hey you tried to divide by
zero that's illegal you can't do that
and we can't handle that so basically
it's throwing this exception so you can
just come up here and click stop
debugging and that'll make that go away
i'm gonna show you guys one other way we
can break this program so if i put a
number in here like a four
that's all well and good right but
remember we're converting whatever is up
there into a number so if i was to type
in like a g
this isn't a number right g is not a
number it has no numerical value so the
program isn't going to be able to
convert g into an integer even though i
asked it to so when i hit enter another
exception is going to get thrown this
time we're getting a format exception it
says input string was not in correct
format in other words we asked you to
enter in a number and you entered in a
character the program can't handle that
so it breaks that's another example of
an exception so the question becomes
what do we do about this right our
program keeps throwing these exceptions
so how can we handle that like if the
user enters in a letter instead of a
number i don't want the program to
terminate i want to be able to do
something else like i want to be able to
yell at them and be like hey you entered
in the wrong thing i don't want the
program to terminate or if the user
tries to divide by zero you don't want
the program to terminate you want to
tell them that they entered in an
invalid number so
if we want to do that we can actually do
something called exception handling
exception handling is basically the
process of catching these exceptions so
we're basically going to tell c sharp
like hey there's some code over here
that might throw an exception if it does
we want you to catch it and instead of
crashing we want to be able to handle it
i'm going to show you guys how we can do
that so we want to use something called
try catch blocks so i'm just going to
type out try and open and close
parentheses
curly bracket
and then down here i'm going to type out
catch and again an open and closed curly
bracket
so try catch blocks work like this any
code that we think is going to break the
program for example the code down here
we can put inside of these try blocks
and if that code does indeed break the
program then instead of the program
terminating the program is going to go
down here into this catch block and it's
going to execute all the code down there
so what i want to do is take all of my
risky code in other words all of this
stuff and i can place it inside of these
try blocks so i'm just going to paste it
inside of here so now all of this code
that potentially would break the program
is inside of this try block so what i
want to show you guys now that i have
this catch block over here i can just do
like console.write
line and over here
i'm just going to print out
error
so essentially what's going to happen
now is if any of this code causes an
exception we're going to come down here
and print out this let me show you guys
i'm gonna go ahead and run this program
and it says enter a number so let's do
the zero one again so now i'm gonna hit
zero this should break the program but
now instead of breaking the program and
causing an exception we just print out
error so it's it's kind of like a backup
system and what we can also do is we can
get more information about the error
that occurred so i can say catch i can
make an open and close parenthesis and
then i can say
exception and i can just call this e so
basically saying that this catch block
is going to take an exception parameter
and we're going to call it e if i came
over here now i could basically print
out e
and i could say e dot
message and this is going to tell me
what went wrong so now when i run my
program and we can do that zero division
i'll say 5 divided by 0 and it's going
to tell me what went wrong it's going to
tell me you attempted to divide by 0. if
i did the other error so for example if
i
entered in a letter like g now it's
going to tell me input string was not in
correct format so it's able to
catch the error that happened and by
saying exception e up here in these
parentheses we can actually get the
error message just like that so this is
a really great way to kind of stop our
programs from terminating but here's the
thing there's all different types of
exceptions that can get thrown inside of
our programs right and all i have down
here is one catch block so no matter
what exception gets thrown we're always
executing this same code down here but
let's say there was a situation where
when the zero division error occurred
you wanted to do one thing and when the
input error occurred you wanted to do a
different thing well you can't really do
that because we only have one catch
block well what we can do is we can
actually define specific exceptions that
we want to catch so down here instead of
saying exception i can actually specify
a specific type of exception that i want
this catch block to catch so before we
were getting a divide by zero exception
so i can put this in here and now this
is only going to catch a divide by zero
exception so if i was to run my program
and we did the divide by zero i'll say
five zero you'll see it's able to catch
it but if i was to do that invalid
format if i came over here and i said
like six and then i set a g
it's not going to be able to catch that
so down here we're getting this format
exception right
and basically it's not being caught
because we didn't specify it down here
this catch block is only going to catch
divide by zero exceptions but what we
can actually do is we could make another
one so i could say catch and in here i'm
just going to type in format exception
and now this is going to be able to
catch any format exceptions that occur
so now i can say console.writeline
and again we can just print out like e
dot message and so the idea is that
instead of just printing out e dot
message you would do something different
depending on the error that gets thrown
in our case though we're just going to
say e dot message so now when i get that
format exception if i say like five and
then g
it's going to say input string was not
in correct format so it's able to catch
both of those and that's essentially
what you want to do so what we were
doing before is we just had like catch
and we were just kind of catching any
exception under the sun
but now we're catching individual
exceptions and this is actually a better
way to do it because we're able to
account for each of these situations
right when the user divides by zero we
could print out like hey you divided by
zero like watch it if they have a format
exception then we could do something
else like maybe we could prompt them to
enter that input again or you know we
could do something else and so being
able to have these multiple catch blocks
is extremely useful there's also one
more thing i want to show you guys which
is called finally so down here i could
just type out
finally and i'm going to make an open
and closed curly bracket and any code
that we put inside of this finally block
is always going to get executed no
matter what right no matter what it's
going to get executed so for example up
here this code like if the user enters
in an invalid number like if they enter
in a letter here instead of a number
this code won't get executed right
because we threw the exception and we
broke and we came down here but
sometimes in your programs even if
something throws an exception you're
always going to want to execute
something and that code can go down here
in the final block but you don't always
need to finally block that's kind of
optional so really this is just how we
can handle different errors in our
program and there's a bunch of different
exceptions if you just go online and you
know search for like c sharp exception
list you'll find a bunch of these
different exceptions and this really
just makes your programs more durable
like before this was a very fragile
program if i entered in a letter instead
of a number like it would just crash and
burn but now we're actually able to
handle all those different situations
using these tri-catch blocks so these
are extremely useful and anytime you
have code that's a little dicey
especially if you're like getting input
from a user stuff like that these can
come in handy
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how to use classes and objects in c
sharp now classes and objects is
actually a big subject and there's a lot
for me to talk about
in this particular topic but this video
is just going to be a very basic
introduction into what classes and
objects are and how we can start using
them in our c sharp programs now in c
sharp we're going to be dealing with all
types of data and a lot of times when
you're writing your programs you're
going to want to work with and represent
different things in your programs and by
default c sharp gives us a bunch of
different data types that we can work
with so in c sharp we can represent
things like
text so we can use strings to represent
text we can represent characters we can
represent whole numbers with integers
and we can represent decimal numbers
with things like doubles and floats
right we can also represent true and
false values with boolean variables but
here's the problem is with just those
limited data types we're not going to be
able to represent or model everything
that we want in our programs in other
words there's a lot of things in the
real world that can't just be
represented using a string or a number
or a boolean right i mean think of
something like a phone for example like
imagine i wanted to represent a phone
inside of my program well i can't
represent a phone with like a string you
know i can't represent a phone with just
a number like a phone is a
complex entity in the real world and i
can't sort of break it down into just
one single like string or number right i
can't represent it using just one of
those data types and that's kind of one
of the limitations that you're going to
encounter is like you can't represent
everything just using one of these data
types so what i want to talk to you guys
about today is something called classes
and objects and classes and objects
essentially allow you to create your own
custom data types by default we're given
things like strings numbers and booleans
but i could actually create my own data
type that would allow me to represent
something that i wanted inside of my
program so generally what we'll do when
we want to create a data type in c sharp
is we'll create something called a class
and a class is basically just a
specification
for a new data type so i could create a
class for a phone or i could create a
class for like a water bottle or i could
create a class for
a keyboard or a computer and then i
could represent all those different
things inside my programs so classes are
basically used to model real world
entities inside of our program so i'm
going to show you guys how we can build
a class in order to do that the first
step we want to build the class is you
want to open up your solution explorer
over here in my case it's just over here
on the right side of my screen and i'm
going to go down to my project so i'm
over here in my draft project and when i
want to create a new class i can just
right click and i'm going to go down to
add and i'm just going to click new item
and then over here we should get this
little menu that pops up and it says
class this is the first one right up
here so i'm going to select that and
then i can actually come down here to
the bottom and give this a name so i'm
going to go ahead and name my class and
generally when we're creating a class in
c sharp you want to name it with a
capital letter so in this situation i
think we should create a class for a
book so let's say that i was writing a
program maybe this was a program for
like a library or a school bookstore and
i wanted to be able to represent a book
inside of my program so i want to create
a book data type so just like i create a
string or i create an integer where i
create a boolean i want to be able to
create an actual book inside of my
program so i'm going to create a book
class and i'm just going to call this
book.cs
and i'll hit enter
and you guys will see over here that
another file has been added to our
solution explorer so now we have this
book.cs file and you'll notice that this
is pretty much laid out exactly like the
other one
so exactly like this program class that
we were using over here
and it's basically just like an empty
class so remember what i said a class is
essentially just a specification for or
really it's like a blueprint for a new
data type in our program and one of the
cool things about c sharp is it actually
allows us to you know specify a custom
data type
and essentially what we want to do is
we're going to be creating a complex
data type so a string for example is a
data type right and all it is is just
plain text a number is a data type and
all it is is just you know a number
right we have integers we have floats
they're whole numbers and decimal
numbers
but when we create this book data type
it's actually going to be composed of
all of those other data types so inside
of here we're going to define a series
of attributes and these attributes are
basically going to describe what a book
is inside of our program and that's
generally what you want to do when you
create a class you're going to take a
class and you're going to give it a
series of attributes and like i said
those attributes will kind of define
what it is so i have this book class and
i want to think about what are the
different attributes that are going to
allow me to represent a book inside of
my program and what i want to do is i
want to actually create variables for
each of those so let's think about this
what are the different attributes of a
book well i can think of the first one
is going to be title so over here i'm
going to say string title and before i
say string title i'm going to say public
so i want to say public
string
title and i'm actually going to make
this lowercase
so that's one attribute that we could
store about a book what's another one
well let's think we would also want to
store the book's author so i can say
public string author
and let's just try to think of one more
so i think one more good one might be
the number of pages so i'm going to say
public
int
pages
and all of these different variables
that we're declaring over here are
called class attributes and these are
essentially pieces of information that
are describing what a book is in our
program so i'm essentially modeling the
book data type i'm creating a blueprint
for the book data type i'm saying that
inside of our program a book is going to
have a title an author and a number of
pages so this is a specification it's a
template now what i can do is i can go
off to my other program and i can
actually create a book inside of my
program so just like i create a string
or i create an integer or i create a
double or a boolean i can create a book
and i can store it inside of a variable
and we can actually create something
called an object which is going to be a
actual book
inside of our program so i'm going to
show you guys how we can do that i'm
going to save this file and i'm going to
head back over to program.cs so this is
like the file that has our main method
over here and i want to show you guys
how we can create a book now so if i
wanted to create and represent an actual
book inside of my program since i
created that class and i defined what a
book is i basically defined the book
data type i can actually do that and i
can create something called an object
and an object is an instance of a class
so when we created the class we created
the template for what a book is when we
create an object we're creating an
actual physical book inside of our
program right so over here this class
specified like a title author pages
right this is a specification for what a
book is when i create a book object i'm
creating an actual book with an actual
title actual number of pages and an
actual author so i'm going to show you
guys how we can do that the first thing
i want to do is i'm basically going to
create this like i would a normal
variable so the first thing i'll do is
specify the data type and in our case
we're going to create a book using the
book data type so just like if i was
creating a string i would say like
string you know whatever is equal to
whatever
here i'm just going to say book and
we're going to do the same thing so i'm
going to say book i'm going to give this
a name so why don't we just call it book
one
and now what i'm going to do is set it
equal to new
book and then open and close parentheses
and this is how we can create what's
called a book
object this is essentially an instance
of a book so this is like a physical
book inside of our program so the class
is a specification the class tells us
what the book data type is an object is
an actual instance
of that class all right so hopefully
that makes sense
so now i've actually created this book
called book one and we can use book one
over here just like a variable i mean
it's essentially just a variable that's
storing a book object so
remember the book has all these
attributes right so a book can have a
title a book can have an author and a
book can have a number of pages so when
we create our book we want to give it
all of those attributes so what i can do
is i can say like book one dot and now i
can access the attribute so i could say
book one dot title and i can actually
give this a value so let's say that we
wanted to create an object that would
represent one of the harry potter books
so i could say book one.title is equal
to harry potter
so now the title of my book is going to
be harry potter let's come down here and
we'll say book one dot author and the
author of the harry potter books is
jk rowling
so i'm going to say book1.author is
equal to jk rowling and then finally
down here we're going to say book1.pages
and let's just say that this harry
potter book has 400 pages in it so what
i did was i created a book object was
which is an instance of the book class
and i was able to define all of the
pieces of information about this book so
i defined what the book's title was i
define what the book's author was and i
defined how many pages the book had and
so now what i can actually do is i can
work with this piece of information so i
could say like
console.writeline
and over here i could print out some
attributes of the book so i could say
like book1 dot title and now when i run
my program it's going to print out the
title of the book we just created so it
should print out harry potter i could do
the same thing for the other attributes
so i could say like book one dot pages
and now we're going to print out however
many pages book 1 has so we're going to
get 400. so essentially i'm creating
here a book right i defined the book
data type in that class and now i'm
creating an actual book inside of my
class which we're calling an object and
what's cool about these objects is i can
create as many objects as i wanted so i
could come down here and i could
actually make another object so i'm
going to copy this guy and i'm actually
going to paste it down here and instead
of being book 1 i'm going to change it
to book 2. so this is going to be book
two book two
book two book two so let's start giving
this some different information let's
say this object is gonna represent one
of the lord of the rings books so i
could say
lord of the rings and then the author is
tolkien and let's say the lord of the
rings has like i don't know 700 pages in
it so now i have a book up here called
book one which is representing the harry
potter book and then i have another book
down here book two
which is representing the lord of the
rings book and i'm actually able to have
an actual book in my program right so
i'm able to
represent and store and work with and
model
a book inside my program so down here i
could do the same with book two i could
say like book two
dot
author and now this is gonna print out
the author of book two
so you'll see over here we get tolkien
now i wanna bring up one point so both
of these objects are books right over
here in this book class i defined the
book data type i basically told c sharp
like hey we got a new data type it's a
book it's awesome all books have a title
and author and a number of pages
and over here i created individual books
off of that blueprint off of that
template
right so book one is its own book it has
its own title its own author and its own
pages book two
down here is another book and it has its
own title its own author and its own
pages so if i was creating an
application for like a library for
example let's say the library had ten
thousand books well i could create 10
000 objects all of which would have the
title
the author and the number of pages of
each one of those books and then i could
work with those books i could pass them
into methods i could use them in if
statements i could do all sorts of stuff
with those books just like i would with
other data types like strings numbers or
booleans so classes and objects are
extremely powerful and really this is
just scratching the surface this is like
lesson one you know this is the bare
basics of working with classes and
objects as we go forward for the next
few videos we're going to learn all
sorts of ways to make these a lot more
powerful
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
guys about using constructors in c-sharp
classes now a constructor is basically a
special method that we can put inside of
a c-sharp class which is going to get
called whenever we create an object of
that class so anytime i create an object
of a specific class the constructor
method will get called and we can do
different things so i'm going to show
you guys how we can leverage that
constructor method in order to make it a
lot easier for us to create
objects off of the classes that we
create in c sharp so down here um if
you're not following along with the
course i basically created a class over
here called book
and i just created this book class and i
basically said that the book is going to
have a title and author
and a number of pages that's kind of all
this book is and then over here in my
program.cs and my main method i created
two books so i created a harry potter
book and i created a lord of the rings
book now i want to show you guys how we
can use a constructor and we're actually
going to be able to use a constructor to
make it a lot easier for us to create
these objects but before we do that i
just want to give you an introduction to
what constructors are and kind of show
you what's happening so over here in my
class i'm actually going to create a
method down here i'm just going to say
public
book i'm going to make an open and close
parentheses and open and close curly
bracket now you'll notice that i said
public and then i said the name of the
class
and this is what's called a constructor
so anytime i make a method like this
where i'm saying public and then the
name of the class this means that this
is going to be the constructor for this
class and like i told you guys before
the constructor is basically a special
method inside of our class that's going
to get called when we create an object
of this class so let me prove that to
you guys i'm going to come down here and
i'm just going to type out console.write
and i'll make an open and close
parentheses and down here i'm just going
to write
creating book okay very simple
now over here in my program and my main
method
i'm going to run this and what you're
going to see is every time i create a
new book this line and this line
that is going to get executed so i'm
going to run the program and you'll see
over here it says creating book and
creating book essentially what's
happening is when i come down here and i
say new
book
what i'm doing here is i'm actually
calling that constructor method so this
right here this line where i'm saying
new book this book is directly linked to
this method over here and again i'm
going to prove this to you so over here
what i'm going to do is i'm going to say
that this book method this constructor
should accept one parameter so i'm going
to say
string name that's all i'm going to say
and then down here i'm just going to
print out name so this method is
accepting one parameter name and then
down here we're going to print it out
now over here
you'll notice i'm already getting errors
and that's because i didn't include a
parameter so i could come over here and
say like
mike and then down here we could pass
another name like john
so now when i run my program it's gonna
print out mike and it's gonna print out
john because i'm calling that book
constructor
awesome so not only does this call that
constructor but from here we can also
pass parameters into that constructor
and that is extremely powerful so i'm
going to show you guys what we can do
with that information now let's talk
about the code that we have over here
you'll notice that i have a bunch of
code here so when i created this harry
potter book it took me four lines of
code right when i created this
book two this lord of the rings book
took me another four lines of code total
of eight eight lines of code just to
create two objects right just to create
two books i had to write out eight lines
of code not only that i had to manually
type out book one dot title is equal to
harry potter book one dot author is
equal to jk wrong like that's a huge
drag you know having to do that every
single time we want to create a book is
extremely annoying
and imagine if we were instead of
creating two books we were trying to
create 10 or 12 or 20 books right it
would take forever because we'd have to
manually go through and you know assign
a title and an author and a number of
pages so this is a totally valid way to
create our object and give it some
attributes but there's actually another
way and we can use that constructor to
do it so essentially what i want to do
is i want to
allow the caller to pass in
a title an author and a number of pages
into this book constructor so when they
create the book i want them to be able
to tell me what the title is going to be
what the author is going to be and what
the number of pages is going to be that
way they can just tell me right away and
i can handle it up front and i did and
then i don't have to say like book one
dot title is equal to whatever book one
dot author is equal to whatever
so let's see if we can wire that up over
here again this book constructor is
going to take in three parameters and we
already saw before
that over here we can pass parameters
into here right so i can pass a
parameter into here and it's going to
get passed into that constructor so i'm
going to say that this constructor is
going to take three parameters the first
is going to be a string and i'm going to
call this a title and this is going to
stand for argument title and you guys
will see why i'm naming this differently
in a second and then i'm going to make
another string i'm going to call it a
author and then i'm gonna make an int
and i'm gonna call it a pages
now essentially what's happening is
whenever we create a book we need to
pass in the title
the author and the number of pages and
so what i can do now is from inside of
this constructor i can just come down
here and i can say
title
is equal to
a title
and basically what i'm saying is this
title up here
the title of the object
is going to be equal to the title that
they passed in
so whenever we create a new book now
we're going to pass in a title and down
here i'm going to say that the title of
the object is going to be equal to a
title and so now instead of having to
say like book1.title is equal to
whatever
now i can just pass the title in over
here
and i'll just assign the title from over
here so essentially doing this is the
same as saying book1.title is equal to
whatever it's the same exact thing
except i can just do it straight from in
here so what we want to do is do this
for each of these attributes so i can
say
author is equal to a author
and then we can say pages is equal to a
pages
and i just want to point out um you can
name these whatever you want so i could
even name this title if i wanted
or i could name this you know whatever
it doesn't matter i'm just using a title
because it kind of shows that this is
the argument that got passed in and it
kind of distinguishes it from the actual
attribute of the object but you can name
it whatever you want all right so now
when we go back over to our program
you'll notice we're getting errors here
and it's basically saying there's no
argument given that corresponds to the
required formal parameter in other words
hey you need to pass in all this
information now so what i can do is i
can take this information from down here
and i can pass it into here so i can
pass in the title harry potter i can
pass in
the author jk rowling and i can pass in
the number of pages 400 so instead of
having to do that manually i can just
get rid of all this and now we have the
same thing so i'm passing in the title
the author and the number of pages and
then over here in the book i'm taking
those parameters that got passed in and
i'm assigning them to the attributes of
the object and that is super cool and
super useful so let's do the same thing
for lord of the rings we can copy this
i'll paste this bad boy up here so i can
get rid of all of this stuff now
and essentially we have the same exact
thing so we went from having eight lines
of code to create these two objects so
now we just have two lines of code one
each and we're passing in
all of these different attributes so
this should actually work and i'm gonna
go ahead and prove that to you so i'm
going to say
console.writeline and i'm going to go
ahead and just print out like book two
dot i don't know title
and so you'll see that this attribute
got set so now i can run my program
and we get a load of the rings so it's
doing exactly the same thing now i also
want to show you if you want you can
modify any of these values so i can
technically come down here and say
book2.title is equal to
the hobbit
and now this is gonna update book two's
title so now when we print it out it's
not gonna be lord of the rings anymore
it's gonna be the hobbit so that's kind
of how this constructor works and that
constructor is super powerful it's an
amazing way for us to be able to create
these objects really quickly and i also
do want to point out that you can have
more than one constructor so i have this
constructor book and it takes a title
and author and a number of pages but if
i wanted i could just create another one
so i could say like public book and this
could take no parameters and i'd still
be able to do this and so now i can have
that and i'll still be able to create a
book just by saying book
book 3 is equal to new book so now i'm
able to create the book like this with
no parameters with no arguments
or i can create the book with a bunch of
arguments so you can create as many of
these uh constructors as you want and
yeah that's kind of the basics of
constructors these are very powerful
what you want to do is just play around
with these right i mean as long as you
understand what's going on like this
constructor over here is directly
related to
me saying book over here then you kind
of like have a good understanding of
what these are
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about object methods in c sharp
an object method is basically just a
method that we can define inside of our
class that the objects of that class can
use to either like find out information
or modify information about themselves
and object methods can be very useful so
i'm going to show you guys just a little
demonstration on how to use them in this
tutorial what i've actually done is i've
created another class in my program so i
created this student class over here
and this student class is pretty simple
i just defined three attributes that are
going to be part of my student class
so every student is going to have a name
a major and a gpa and then down here i
have a constructor so i'm just sort of
passing in the name the major and the
gpa and i'm assigning them down here so
this is a very simple class
a lot like the class we created in the
last tutorial with constructors
so
now that i have the student class i went
over to my program and i actually
created a couple students so i had these
variables student one and student two
and then i created these student objects
so one is his name is jim he's a
business major and he has a 2.8 gpa
and then we have pam she's an art major
and she has a 3.6 gpa so
these are two objects that i've created
from that student class and i want to
show you guys how we can put a method
inside of that student class that these
student objects can use to find out some
information what i want to do is i want
to be able to figure out whether or not
each of these students is on the honor
roll
right so let's say that we're you know
modeling students for a college or
university and the rules at that college
are that if you have a gpa of 3.5 or
greater then you have honors so you're
on the honor roll i want to be able to
find out whether or not pam and jim are
on the honor roll really easily so one
way i can do that is by creating an
object method so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to come over here to my class
and down below this constructor i'm
going to create a method so i'm actually
going to create a method that is going
to tell us whether or not the student
has honors so i'm going to come down
here and i'm just going to say
public
and i'm going to say bool because we're
going to return a boolean value
essentially this method is going to
return a true if the student has honors
or it's going to return false if the
student doesn't have honors so now i'm
just going to call this has honors
and i'm gonna make an open and close
parenthesis and an open and closed curly
bracket so inside of here we can start
writing out the code to tell if a
student has honors now remember what i
said before was if a student has a gpa
of 3.5 or above that means they're on
the honor roll so what i can do is i can
just use a simple if statement and i can
just say if and i'll come down here and
i'll just say if
gpa is greater than or equal to 3.5
then i'm gonna come over here and i'm
basically going to return true so i'm
just going to return true
and if that's not the case then i'll
come down here and we'll just return
false so in the case that the gpa is
greater than 3.5 we'll hit this line of
code which is telling us to return true
and we'll exit the method and if this is
false so if the gpa isn't greater than
3.5 then we'll come down here and return
false so this is obviously a very simple
method but it's going to come in handy
with our objects so i'm going to head
back over here
and basically what i can do now is i can
figure out whether student 1 or student
2 is on the honor roll so i could come
down here and i can just print this out
so i'll say console
right line and what i want to do is i
want to print out whether or not each of
these students has honors so i'm
actually going to copy this and
i'll come over here and i'll say
student1.has honors
and then we can also stay
student two dot has honors
all right so i'm printing out if whether
or not student one has honors and i'm
printing out whether or not student two
has honors now
what should happen is student one dot
has honor should return false because
jim has a 2.8 gpa jim's not that smart
and this line down here student two dot
has honor should return true because pam
has a 3.6 pam's pretty smart
so let's go ahead and run our program
and we'll see what happens
so you'll see over here we got exactly
what we thought we would we got false
and true now one of the cool things
about the method that we wrote over here
in this student class is that this
method is actually going to use
different information depending on what
object is calling it so
when the gym object calls it when
student one calls it it's going to use
jim's gpa so when jim calls this method
it's going to use jim's gpa of a 2.8
when pam calls this method when that pam
object calls it it's going to use pam's
gpa of 3.6 so we can specify one method
here we only need to write it one time
and the different objects will be able
to use it and they'll be able to use it
with their own information so jim calls
this method and uses his gpa pam calls
this method and uses her gpa and that's
why these methods can be so powerful
because we can define one method and
then different objects can use it and
they can get different information back
depending on the value of their
attributes
another cool thing about this method is
if i ever wanted to change the
qualification for honors so let's say
that i wanted to change honors from
being 3.5 to being 2.5 so now i'm saying
any student who has a 2.5 or above
can have honors well now
i only had to change the code right here
and when i run this program again now
they're both going to have honors so
that value is going to be automatically
updated for both of these objects just
by changing it in that one spot and
that's what's so powerful about these
methods is they basically allow me to
define different rules for my objects so
like i can define what it means to have
honors in my program and i can change it
around if i want and it's not really
going to matter because the objects are
just calling this method and it's
telling them whether or not they have
honors so that's why this is useful and
in the next couple of videos we're going
to be looking at some other ways that we
can use some methods just like this but
basically all you need to know is that
you can make as many of these as you
want right so i can make a method over
here that tells me whether or not uh you
know
a specific rule so that i could it could
tell me whether or not the students have
honors i could also make a method that
would modify one of these values so
nothing is stopping me from coming in
here and saying
gpa is equal to 90.4 right i could
modify each of these students gpas if i
wanted to you can basically do anything
you would do in a normal method so play
around with these um you know i'm sure
you can think of a couple different uh
you know methods that you can create
inside of your classes they can be
really awesome
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about using getters and setters
in c-sharp now a getter and a setter are
basically two types of methods that we
can define inside of our
c-sharp classes which will essentially
control the access that people have to
the attributes of those classes and
essentially what this does is it kind of
like makes your classes more secure so
it kind of allows you to define like
what data is valid for specific
attributes and what data isn't valid and
really gutters and setters are extremely
useful and there's a lot of different
scenarios where you want to use them in
this tutorial i'm going to show you guys
one specific scenario we're going to
talk about like how to set these up and
essentially just how they work
so what i've done in preparation for
this tutorial is i actually created
another class it's this movie class over
here
and this movie class is very simple it's
basically just modeling a movie inside
of our program so this is sort of like
you know the template for the movie data
type and i said that every movie is
going to have a title a director and a
rating and then down here i created this
constructor where i basically passed in
the title of director and rating and i
assigned all of those values so this is
a very simple class and you know like i
said it's just modeling a basic movie
and then over here in my program i
created two movies so i have one called
avengers and it's just the avengers with
director joss whedon and it's pg-13 and
then we have shrek with director adam
adamson and it's rated pg so pretty
simple program right we're basically
just creating a couple different movies
but
here's one of the problems that we
actually have with this program and it
might not be super obvious right away
but the problem has to do with the movie
rating
right now generally when movies have
ratings they can only have specific
ratings right so if we have a movie like
generally it's only going to be able to
be g pg pg 13
r or nr right and maybe there's some
more ratings whatever but let's just say
that these are all the valid ratings
that we can have for a movie so a movie
can either be rated g p g p 213 r or n r
for not rated and let's say that we want
to enforce these rules inside of this
movie class so we want all the movies in
our programs to only be able to have one
of these ratings and it can't have a
rating other than the ones that i
specified down here right well the
problem is how do we enforce something
like that
right because what i could do is i could
easily come over here and change the
rating of avengers to dog for example
and now if i was to come down here and
print out the avengers rating for
example if i came down here said
console.writeline
avengers.rating when i print this out
it's actually going to
print out the rating so it's going to be
able to print out dog so dog was the
rating that we gave to it but dog isn't
one of the valid ratings down here
another thing i could do is even if i
set this to pg-13 over here so if this
was like set to pg-13 i could still come
over here and manually set it so i could
still say like avengers dot rating
is equal to you know dog over here and
it's going to be the same scenario right
i'm still able to set this value equal
to dog so what i want to show you guys
is how we can prevent this from
happening in other words how can we make
it so that the only possible ratings for
the movies are one of these
five ratings that i defined down here we
can actually use something called
getters and setters and in order to use
these getters and setters we're going to
have to modify a couple things so the
first thing that we want to do is we
want to close off access to this rating
property
this rating attribute and what i can do
is i can actually come over here to my
program and you'll see that all of these
attributes are public so we have public
title
public director and public rating and i
haven't really talked about this too
much yet but public essentially means
that these can be accessed by anyone so
any other program any other code that
we're dealing with can access any of
these attributes so public just means
it's open to everybody it's open to the
world but there's actually another
modifier that we can put in front of
here and instead of saying public i
could say private
and what this means when i say private
this means that only code inside of this
movie class is going to be able to
access the rating so only code that is
contained inside of these curly brackets
over here in the side of this movie
class is going to be able to access this
and you'll see now when i go over to
program
i'm getting an error down here so
essentially what this is saying is we
can't access the rating because it's
private so because the code over here is
inside of the program class and it's not
inside of the movie class it's not going
to be able to access the rating so
that's the first step in being able to
enforce these ratings is we need to make
the rating field private so i need to
cut off access from anybody else now the
next thing i want to do is i want to
create two things called getters and
setters so we're going to create getters
and setters for this rating attribute
and basically what these are going to
allow us to do is it's going to allow
outside code for example the code inside
of this program class like down here
it's going to allow code like this to
both access the rating and modify and
set the rating so those getters and
setters are going to be really important
and we can define those through what are
called properties and a property is
basically just like it's kind of like a
little method but it's a special method
that's going to basically allow us to
define a getter and setter so what i
want to do is i can just say public
and i can just say string
and what i want to do is name this
generally what you're going to do is
you're going to name it the same as the
attribute over here but in capital
letters so i'll name this public string
rating and then down here i'm going to
make an open and close curly bracket
and inside of here i need to define two
things or i don't need to but i'm going
to define two things so i can just say
get and i'm going to make an open and
close curly bracket and then i'm going
to say set and i'm going to make an open
and close curly bracket and these are
essentially going to be getters and
setters so a getter is going to allow us
to get the rating attribute you'll
notice over here i'm trying to get this
rating attribute by saying
avengers.rating but i'm not able to do
it right i can't actually access this
rating because it's private and so the
job of the getter is to give me that so
i'm just going to come over here and
inside this get we're just going to say
return
rating and i'm going to put a semicolon
there and so basically whenever we say
rating now and we want to get it it's
going to return the rating now this
setter is going to allow us to set the
rating so it's going to allow me to
modify the rating so if i came over here
and said
avengers dot rating and you can already
see it's trying to make me use this
capital letter
is equal to dog it's going to yell at me
because this is a private attribute so
it's not going to let me do that
and that's what the that's the point of
this setter the setter is basically
going to allow me to do that so
what i can do in this setter though is i
can define a specific rule so i can
basically say like hey you can only set
this value to be a certain value and so
what i want to do is i want to check to
see if the value is one of the valid
ratings and if it is if the value
they're trying to set rating to is one
of the valid ratings then we're gonna go
ahead and set it otherwise we're just
gonna do something else so i wanna say
if and i wanna check to see if the value
that they passed in in other words the
value that they're trying to set to
rating is equal to one of the valid
ratings so what we can actually do is we
can say if
value and value is going to represent
whatever got passed in so value is going
to represent whatever they're trying to
set the rating to so i can say if value
is equal to and we're just going to do
one for all of these so if the value is
equal to g or
value is equal to pg
and i'm going to do this one for each of
the valid ratings so i can just say or
value is equal to and over here we can
just put pg-13 so i'm going to say pg 13
and we're just going to do two more so
value is equal to r and then the last
one is going to be for nr so then over
here i'll say or value
is equal to nr
so if it's equal to one of these in
other words if the value that we pass in
is equal to one of these then we're
going to be able to just set that as the
rating so i can just say
rating is equal to value
otherwise though
i'm just going to set the rating equal
to nr so i'm just going to say
rating is equal to nr so if they add in
an invalid rating in other words if they
add in a rating if they try to set this
to a rating that's not g
pg
pg13r or nr then it's just going to get
set to not rated by default so this
getter is going to allow us to get the
rating and this setter is going to allow
us to set the rating but you'll notice
that in order to set the rating we have
to go through this if statement right so
they can try to pass in whatever rating
they want but if it's not equal to g p
gpg 13 etc then it's just going to get
set equal to not rating and the reason
we needed these getters and setters was
because
we made this guy up here private so
there's one more thing we have to do in
order to make this super secure in other
words there's one more thing that we
have to do to make sure that
the rating is only set to one of these
values up here in my constructor when i
set the rating right here i'm just
assigning it a normal value so
technically the user could pass in
whatever rating they wanted over here
and then i'm just going to set it to the
rating but now instead i'm just going to
say rating is equal to a rating and what
this means is now we're going to set the
rating through this setter down here
when i use this capital r
it's essentially calling this
setter down here and setting it that way
so now this is completely secure
and down here what i can do now is i can
set this to whatever i want and it's
going to be safe so down here i can say
avengers dot rating so i'm using this
capital r now
and over here if i wanted i could pass
in an invalid rating so i could pass in
like dog over here and when i print it
out you'll see that we're gonna get nr
so we're not gonna get
dog we're actually gonna get nr and
that's because we had to go through that
setter and the same goes for anything
else so i could say down here like shrek
dot
rating is equal to
cat
and if we tried to print out
shrek.rating then we're going to get nr
because it's going to get filtered out
by that setter but here's the thing if i
wanted to set this to a valid rating
like if i set shrek.rating equal to r
now it's going to be able to take that
rating because it's valid so that's kind
of how we can use getters and setters
and a lot of times what people will do
is they'll create getters and setters
for each of the
attributes inside of their classes you
don't have to but a lot of times it can
be useful so what you want to do is just
play around with that and you know
basically these just make your class
more secure so they make it so someone
couldn't for example give your movie an
invalid rating
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
guys about static attributes in classes
in c sharp now a static attribute is
basically a special type of attribute in
a class which is shared by all of the
objects and all the instances of that
class so a static attribute is
technically an attribute that is
contained on the class itself instead of
on the individual objects of that class
and i'm going to sort of explain to you
how this works over here in my program i
actually created a class
and it's called song and this class
basically just models a song in our
program so it's kind of like a blueprint
for what a song should be in our program
songs have a title an artist and a
duration
and then down here i just have this
basic constructor which allows the
caller to create the object right up
front so over here in my program i
created two songs one's called holiday
one's called cashmere
this is holiday by green day and i just
said it was 200 seconds and then
cashmere by led zeppelin 150 seconds so
we have our two song objects and i want
to show you guys how we can actually
create a static attribute on this song
class so one thing i want to point out
is there's these normal attributes that
we have over here on this song class
like the title the artist and the
duration if i was to come down here and
print these out
so for example i could come down here
and i could print out
holiday.title
and then right after it i could also
print out cashmere.title
and if i was to do this you'll notice
that both of these objects have
different titles so the first object's
title is
holiday the second is cashmere i could
do the same thing for the other
attributes so if i came down here and
said
holiday.artist and
cashmere.artist they're going to have
different artists right in other words
there's two
different values that are assigned to
the attributes of those objects right so
when i create an object in my program
i'm basically allowing it to have its
own title its own artist and its own
duration so each individual object will
have their own title their own artist
and their own duration right those
things are going to differ across all of
the objects and that is what we would
consider a normal attribute but there's
another type of attribute which is
called a static attribute and a static
attribute is an attribute that isn't
unique to each one of the objects in
other words a static attribute is an
attribute about the actual class
so this title attribute like i said it's
different for each of the objects so
holiday.title and cashmere.title those
are different values but a static
attribute is going to be the same across
all of the objects of a class in fact a
static attribute is basically just an
attribute that we would say is about the
class so let me show you guys um
basically what this is i'm going to come
down here and i'm going to create a
static attribute you can create it
similar to these ones i can just say
public
static so i'm using this static keyword
here and then i'm going to give it a
type and i'm just going to call this
song count
and basically what this variable is
going to do is it's going to tell us how
many song objects have been created so
i'm just going to set this equal to 0
initially so i'm giving it an initial
value now i want to show you guys what
we can actually do with this static
variable
because we have this static attribute i
could actually come over here
and instead of saying like
holiday.artist i could actually say
song dot
song count
and i could actually print this out so
i'm gonna print this out
and you'll see that we should just get
zero because that's what i set it to
initially so
unlike the artist the title and the
duration
the song count attribute is actually on
this class so i couldn't say song.title
because title isn't an attribute that's
associated with song you'll see down
here we're getting this error i couldn't
say song dot
artist
because artist is going to apply to the
objects of the class not the class
itself but i can say song dot song count
because this is a static attribute which
is which means it belongs to the class
so that's kind of the difference and i
want to show you guys um something we
could actually do so over here i have my
constructor right this is a constructor
method it's a very simple constructor
anytime that we create a song object so
anytime a song object gets created this
method gets called it's a guarantee
right
basically when i come over here and i
say
new song this is me calling that
constructor so anytime we create one of
these songs it's going to get called so
what i'm going to do down here is every
time we create a song in other words
after all this code in the constructor
i'm just going to increment the song
count so i'm going to say song count
plus plus
so basically what's going to happen is
every single time a song object gets
created the song count is going to get
incremented so let me show you guys how
this is going to work over here i'm
actually just going to
i'm going to get rid of this guy
and i'm going to copy this and i'm going
to go ahead and paste it
in between here
so in between hot the creating holiday
and creating cashmere we're printing out
the song count so let's see what happens
what we should get is one and two so
basically when we create holiday and
then we print out the song count one
song's been created so we get a one over
here then we create this cashmere object
and so that song counts gonna get
incremented again and here we get two
so this static attribute is telling us
information not about the specific
objects themselves but about the class
in general right so i can figure out how
many objects have been created of the
song class right how many instances of
the song class have been created in my
program
but that's not a piece of information
that is going to be specific to the
holiday object or to the cashmere object
that is a piece of information that's
going to be specific to the class itself
and that's basically what a static class
attribute is it's an attribute about the
class not about the specific objects of
the class so it's basically an attribute
that we store to kind of you know give
us information about that class and you
can create uh static attributes you can
create as many as you want and honestly
they can be really useful and you'll
notice that whenever we access them we
don't say like i wouldn't say like
cashmere dot
song count like i'm i'm not going to be
able to do that
so we have to access it through the
actual class now one thing that we could
do is we could create a method so i
could come over here and i could create
a method so i could say like
public
get song count
and
actually this is going to return an
integer
and then over here i could actually
return the song count so i could say
like
and now we're actually going to be able
to access the song count on each of our
individual objects so i could
technically come down here and say
cashmere dot
get
song count and now we'll be able to get
the song count um off of one of those
objects so you'll see now that we can
get two just like we did before
so you can either just create a static
attribute and access it using like song
dot song count like i did over here or
you could create a getter method like
get song count and then the individual
objects could access that and both of
those can be uh pretty useful sometimes
you're going to want the objects to be
able to have access to those static
attributes but that's sort of an
overview of static attributes and really
that static keyword and actually as we
go forward i'm going to show you some
other cool stuff we can do with that
static keyword
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how to use static methods in
classes now a static method is basically
just a method that belongs to the class
itself so a lot of times when we create
methods inside of our c-sharp classes
usually those methods will be used on
objects so
we could have an object of a specific
class and then that object could use
those methods to you know do different
things
but a static method in a class is a
method that belongs to the actual class
which means you don't have to create an
object of that class in order to use it
and access it and these can be extremely
useful and there's a lot of
circumstances where you want to create
classes that have static methods inside
of them so i'm going to show you guys
basically how that works now down here
you'll see that i have this little line
it just says console.writeline and then
over here i'm saying math.squareroot144
right essentially what's happening here
is there's this class in c sharp which
is called math
and inside of that math class there's a
bunch of these methods now one thing
you'll notice here when i went to access
this square root method inside the math
class i didn't have to create an
instance of the math class and normally
up to this point in the course whenever
we wanted to use a class or use any of
the functionality that a class described
we had to create an object so i would
have to say like math
my math is equal to new math right i'd
have to create an actual instance of the
math class like that
but you'll notice that down here i
didn't have to do that right in fact
when i try to create an instance of the
math class i'm getting this error over
here so down here i can basically just
say math dot square root and i'm able to
use this method without having to create
an instance of the math class and this
is an example of a static method so a
static method like i said it's a method
that belongs to the class which means we
don't have to create an instance of the
class in order to use it so i could go
ahead and run this program and we should
get back the square root of 144 so we
should get back 12. i'm going to show
you guys how we can do this and how we
could basically create something similar
to the math class so up here i'm going
to create a new class and you can either
come over here right click and go to add
and then click new item or we can also
go up here and we can click project and
click add class so i'm going to do it
this way and then over here you can see
i'm just clicking on class and why don't
we just call this
useful tools so this is going to be our
useful tools class and you'll see over
here that i basically just have class
useful tools and inside of this class if
i wanted to create static methods all i
have to do is come down here and i can
just say like public
static and i could create a method so
why don't we create one called say hi
and it's going to take one parameter so
it's going to take a string name
and then
we will basically just have this say hi
so it's going to
console.writeline and we're just going
to print out
hello
name
and actually whoops forgot to put a
return type here so this should be void
so public static void say hi string name
and it just prints out hello to whatever
name gets passed in extremely simple
method over there so what i could do is
i could actually come down here and i
could access that method directly
without creating an instance of the
useful tools class so down here i can
just get rid of this and we can just go
ahead and call this directly so i could
say
useful tools dot
say hi so i didn't actually have to
create an instance of the useful tools
class all i all i did was just access
this method directly so i could pass in
my name like mike and now we'll be able
to run this method without having to
create an instance of the useful tools
class you can see over there
everything's running just fine now this
is an extremely useful thing so what you
could actually do is you could create a
class over here and it could just be
contained of you know these static
methods and that's essentially what that
math class is that we looked at before
the math class is basically just a class
that has a bunch of these static methods
inside of it that are used to do
different things so if you just have a
normal class you know maybe a class
that's modeling some sort of real world
entity you can include static methods
inside of there and then the callers
don't have to create instances of that
class in order to use them another thing
you could do is set up a class that is
solely designed for this purpose so for
example that math class that math class
is actually what's called a static class
so you'll notice when i tried to create
a instance of that math class before i
said like math my math
is equal to new
math i'm not actually able to create an
instance of the math class you'll see
i'm getting an error here and this is
because the math class is a static class
which means you can't create an instance
of it
but you'll notice with this useful tools
class
could create an instance of it
and it's going to be no problem so like
this is actually like a useful tools
object so in certain circumstances
you're going to want to do that like
you're going to want to be able to have
a class with static methods
that can have an object created of it
but in situations like with that math
class you're not going to want to do
that so what you can do is you can come
over here and we can just say
static class useful tools and now we're
not going to be able to create an
instance of the useful tools class
you'll see down here i'm getting this
error now basically says cannot declare
a variable of static type useful tools
and then over here it says cannot create
an instance of the static class useful
tools so
that's sort of like two different ways
that you can use this but these static
methods are extremely useful and like i
said there's a lot of situations where
you're going to want to use them
basically just to define functionality
on the class level instead of on the
individual object level
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about inheritance in c sharp
now inheritance is basically a technique
that we can use in c sharp where we can
have one class inherit all of the
functionality of another class so i'm
going to find something called a super
class and then i can actually create
classes that are going to inherit all
the functionality from that super class
called subclasses so i'm just going to
give you guys a very basic introduction
into inheritance this is a huge subject
and there's a lot that you can kind of
get into with inheritance so i just want
to show you guys like the basic concept
of what's happening with it so over here
in my program i created a class it's
called
chef.cs and this is a class that
basically like represents a chef in our
program so you can see here class chef
and this chef has uh three methods that
it can use so the first one here is
called make chicken and basically all
this does is it prints out
the chef makes chicken right so the chef
can make chicken the chef can also make
salad so it says the chef makes salad
and the chef can also make a special
dish so it just says the chef makes
barbecue ribs so this is a you know a
pretty cool class it's obviously a very
simple class but it's you know it can
basically represent a chef in our
program so down here in my program.cs in
my main method i created a chef object
and it's just called chef and then i
basically just said chef dot make
chicken so i'm telling the chef to make
some chicken and when i run my program
now
it's going to say the chef makes chicken
right so hopefully that makes sense um
you know i just have this chef class
over here and i defined some methods in
there and then i created an object of
the chef class
and told it to make chicken now i want
to show you guys how we can use
inheritance to make a
another type of class so let's say that
in addition to having just a normal chef
like we defined over here i also wanted
to have a more specialized type of chef
so i wanted to represent not just not
only just a general chef in my program
but also a more specialized chef so
let's say i'll come up here and i'm
gonna say project add class
and i'm gonna create a class called
italian chef
so
italian chef is not just going to be a
normal chef he's going to be a italian
chef
and i'm going to go ahead and create
this class so you'll see over here we
have this class italian chef now let's
say that this italian chef can do
everything that the normal chef could do
right so this italian chef is a really
awesome chef and not only can he just
cook regular food but he can also cook
like more specifically italian food so
let's say the italian chef can do
everything that the normal chef can do
so the italian chef can also make
chicken the italian chef can also make
salad and the italian chef can also make
a special dish so
the italian chef is very similar to the
normal chef right he can do everything
that the normal chef can do you can also
do some other stuff as well one thing i
could do to give the italian chef all of
this functionality is i could just copy
and i could paste all of these methods
over here
right and so now the italian chef is
able to make chicken able to make salad
and able to make a special dish right
but in c sharp there's actually
something that we can do in a situation
like this so anytime you have a class
like italian chef that can do everything
and that has all the same functionality
and attributes as another class like
this chef class we can use something
called inheritance and inheritance is
basically the process of inheriting all
of the functionality all the attributes
etc from a class like chef into a class
like italian chef so what i could do is
i could come over here and i could say
italian chef and i can make a colon
and i can just say chef and basically
what this means is that the italian chef
is going to inherit all the
functionality from the chef class so now
the italian chef can do everything that
the chef class can do
and i'm going to come over here and
prove that to you guys so i'm going to
create an italian chef object so i'm
just going to copy this guy and i'm
going to paste this down here and i'm
just going to change everything to
italian chef
so i went ahead and changed this to
italian chef it's called italian chef
and we said new italian chef and now i'm
saying italian chef dot make chicken now
i'm s i'm calling the make chicken
method on the italian chef object but
you'll notice over here in the italian
chef class declaration i don't actually
have any methods specified so i didn't
specify like a make chicken method or
anything like that but what you'll see
is because i inherited all of the
functionality from the chef class i'm
actually still able to make chicken with
the italian chef so when i run my
program you'll see that it says the chef
makes chicken and this is that normal
chef and then down here the italian chef
is also able to make chicken because the
italian chef inherited all the
functionality from the normal chef and
that's kind of cool so that's basically
what you can do if you have like two
classes and in c sharp we would refer to
chef as the super class and we would
refer to italian chef as the subclass
and the subclass is always going to be
inheriting functionality from the super
class so that's just a little
terminology now we can actually take
this a step further so
let's say that the italian chef in
addition to being able to make chicken
salad and a special dish can also do
something else so we could add another
method in here i could say like public
void and we'll just call this like make
pasta so in addition to making all that
other stuff the italian chef can also
make pasta
so now this chef can also make pasta and
forgot to put an open enclosed
parentheses there so if i was to come
over here to my program i could say
italianchef.make
and the italian chef is going to be able
to make pasta so let's run that
and you'll see over here he's making
pasta but what you'll notice is this
normal chef can't make pasta so if i
tried to make pasta on the normal chef
it's not going to be able to do that so
that's going to throw an error and
that's because we only define make pasta
in the sub class
not in the super class so that's kind of
how that's going to work out and i want
to show you guys one more thing we can
do so you'll notice over here in my chef
class i have this method it's called
make special dish right and the chef is
making a special dish of barbecue ribs
right so this chef's special dish is
going to be barbecue ribs but let's say
that the italian chef doesn't want to
make barbecue ribs as a special dish so
let's say that the italian chef's
special dish is actually like some other
type of dish and it's not a barbecue
dish well the problem is when i come
over here and i say
make special dish and i say
make special dish both of these chefs
are going to be making the same special
dish so when i run the program they're
both making barbecue ribs but remember i
don't want the italian chef to make
barbecue ribs i want the italian chef to
make something else as their special
dish well in a situation like this i can
do something called overriding a method
overriding a method basically means that
i take one of the methods that i've
inherited like this make special dish
method and i override it so i basically
come over here into this italian chef
class and i override the functionality
of that method now in order to do this
we're gonna have to do one thing over
here in the chef class and we're gonna
have to include this virtual keyword so
you'll notice i already have this in
here so up here on these two methods it
says public void make chicken public
void make salad but down here on make
special dish i've given it this special
keyword public virtual void make special
dish and when we specify this as virtual
basically that means that this method
can be overridden in any subclasses so
when i say virtual it basically means
that subclasses can change the
functionality of this method so i can
just copy this method and i'm just going
to go ahead and paste it down here
and you'll see here i'm saying public
virtual void make special dish but
instead of saying virtual here in the
subclass so i'm in my italian chef class
i'm going to say
override and this is basically telling c
sharp that we're gonna override the make
special dish method
from the super class and then down here
i can change it so i could say the chef
makes instead of barbecue ribs why don't
we say like
chicken parm
so now when the italian chef makes a
special dish it's going to be making
chicken parm
instead of making barbecue ribs so let's
go over here into our program and you'll
see i'm still printing out chef.make
special dish and
italianchef.makespecialdish
when i run the program
they're printing out different special
dishes so the italian chef successfully
overrode the functionality of one of the
methods that it inherited from the super
class and that is extremely useful so
those are
three very core concepts in inheritance
so the first is just inheriting all of
the functionality from a superclass the
second is extending that functionality
so for example
in addition to being able to do
everything that the normal chef could do
the italian chef could also make pasta
and then finally we were able to
override one of the functions or one of
the methods that we inherited using this
override keyword on the subclass and
using this virtual keyword on the
superclass so
that is sort of the basics of
inheritance and like i said there's you
know inheritance is a very complex
subject and there's a lot lot of stuff
that you can do with it but this is kind
of just an overview of essentially how
it works so now you kind of have the
concepts down in your mind and you can
kind of go forward and
learn more specific ways to use it
hey thanks for watching if you enjoyed
the video please leave a like and
subscribe